Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Wenn jemand so etwas Schlimmes mit Kindern macht, dann ist das richtig.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundsiebzehn direkt aus der Metaebene äh nicht so live, wie es aufgenommen wird, aber äh schön aus der Konserve in eure Ohren,
Und der Dimus ist da und der Tim ist da und wir erzählen euch wieder Märchen aus dem Cyberwald,
da tummeln sich wieder ganz trollige Wichte und äh überhaupt eine ganze Menge los.
Ähm abgesehen davon, dass das äh sonstige Weltgeschehen irgendwie von Hirntoten wahnsinnigen äh vorangetrieben wird, wo man einfach aus dem Kopf schütteln nicht mehr rauskommt.
Äh du meinst die Bombardierung des Irak? Ja. Ane Syrien.
Ja. Äh ja Syrien, ja genau. Ja, also ich meine.
Michael Weil Hitler ist so tief gesunken, den Irak zu bombardieren.
Ja, also der Hitler wusste zumindest, wen er angreift.
Man kann hier nicht viel zugute halten, so. Ich glaube, er wusste schon noch.
Auf jeden Fall, ne.
Ja, also die Länder.
Was ich auch sehr schön finde ist, dass die NATO jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr obsolet ist, ne.
Ja, sie ist jetzt worden.
Endopsolotisiert worden. So, diese Woche ist NATO wieder wichtig.
Mike Trump sich mit wie du.
Hat gar keinen Sinn, ne?
Ich, wir haben ja häufig das Feedback, dass die dass wir hier nicht über Trump reden sollen, weil überall sonst über Trump geredet wird. Aber ich habe inzwischen so ein bisschen das haben wir auch lange gefehlt. Ähm.
Ich finde es jetzt schön, dass wir uns nicht mehr in den beknacktesten Politikfeld mit unserem Podcast aufhalten.
Also du hast irgendwie so du hast äh Abstimmung in der Türkei jetzt dieses Wochenende glaube ich du hast äh Trump, du hast dir dieses gesamte Idiotenmaschinerie, ja? Und wir sind so im, in so einem.
Seriösen Feld.
Ich sag mal, wir haben den Kindergarten inzwischen unter Kontrolle.
Die meisten sind Porty Trains so, ähm aber weißt du?
Bei uns wird halt am Ende nicht ganz so viel Schokokuchen gegessen und es wird zwar immer schlimmer, aber graduell.
Und es ist nicht so wie in so einer Geisterbahn, wo immer ich irgendwie so Nuklearschlag hier äh irgendwie eine die heute nochmal insofern bei uns ist es noch so.
Bürgerlich, ne? Diegen sind philosophisch. Gibt auch Gerichte, die Urteil oder Gremien, die befragt werden, so.
Ich wollte ein bisschen Feedback mal äh vorlesen zur letzten Sendung
ähm waren wie immer mehrere wichtige Kommentare dabei. Ähm ich habe jetzt aber nur einige wenige rausgegriffen. Gleichzeitig
es noch andere wichtige, die jetzt, die ich jetzt nicht rausgegriffen habe. Einmal kurzer Hinweis zur Frage, ob man seine Urheberrechte verletzenden Kinder,
verraten muss, entschied nicht das OEG München, sondern der BGH. Das ist richtig, das VMPGH-Urteil
und ähm es gab nur irgendwie vorher ein
Urteil des OLG München, dass da auch in meinen Notizen war und da ich immer so mit einem Auge auf die Notizen schiede, bin ich, da habe ich da im Gericht verrutscht,
Ja, ich bin aber richtig. Was interessiert uns hier so ein OLG München.
Ja darüber berichten wir doch nicht. Ähm dann.
Cyberwehr, für Cyberwerke, also zur Cyberbundeswehr, aber das muss man ja glaube ich so ein bisschen trennen, ne? Also die Cyberwehr ist ja diese freiwilligen Initiative des BSI und das, was uns.
Kommando Ziere ist ja das von der Bundeswehr. Aber jetzt wird jetzt hier gerade so ein bisschen gemischt. Zum ein paar Bemerkungen zum Thema Cyberbundeswehr. Ich war vor wenigen Jahren als,
FWD DELA in der Ob-Infotruppe,
die inzwischen im Zentrum für operative Kommunikation aufgegangen ist. Dabei handelt es sich nicht viel von Linus vermutet, um einen Bereich, der sich mit Verschlüsselung auseinandersetzt, sondern um eine Einheit,
Die Medienangebote für die eigene Truppe, zum Beispiel Radio Andernach, beziehungsweise die Zivilbevölkerung in Form von Audiovideo und Printprodukten erstellt.
Diese Truppe hat sich zumindest zu meiner Zeit, zwanzig, zwölf, zwanzig, dreizehn nicht durch eine besondere Affinität zur Produktion von Medien erhalten
Inhalten oder gar besonderen
IT-Kenntnissen hervorgetan. Denkbar wäre daher, dass diese Truppe analog zu ihrem bisherigen Aufgaben künftig auch über soziale Medien wirken soll. Und deshalb in die Bundeswehr mit Bundecyberwehr mit einbezogen wurde. Oder
Man ist bei der Bundeswehr einfach so verzweifelt, dass man alle Arbeitsstellen, die irgendwie mit Computern zu tun haben. Ähm.
In dieser neuen Truppe gebündelt hat und zumindest auf dem Papier über eine starke Cyberwehr verfügen möchte. Also noch weitere,
Erklärung, wir haben ja auch gesagt, dass wir da relativ wenig,
Checkung von haben, von den internen Organisationsstrukturen der Bundeswehr und gerade mit diesen Begriffen also da waren jetzt auch schon wieder zwei Wörter drin, die ich nicht kenne, die muss man kennen, ne? FBD Ella oder.
Das ist freiwilliger Wehrdienst leist.
Freiwillige Berlin zu essen, ja. Und ob Info als operative Infohörer.
Okay, siehste, ist alles gar nicht so einfach. Äh gar nicht so so schwer. Dann noch ein ähm Einkommen, ein etwas längeren Kommentar von Christoph. Lieber Linus, lieber Tim,
Ihr und der gesamte CC
Macht regelmäßig klar, dass hier eine Beteiligung bei der Cyberwehr, sowie bei nationalen Strafverfolgsbehörden ausschließt, beziehungsweise ratet jedem ratet jedem anderen davon ab. Ganz persönlich finde ich schon,
dass ein Staat in einer Welt, wo Spionage, Propaganda, Sabotage und Angriffe, seien sie krimineller Natur oder internationaler Konflikte,
oder Teil internationaler Konflikte auch über Computer, Netzwerke und das Internet geführt werden.
Nicht umhin kann hier Kompetenzen aufzubauen und neue Arten von Straftaten und Angriffen zu begegnen
Der Satz war ein bisschen lang und ich habe ihn schlecht vorgelesen, aber das Kernargument ist in dieser Welt wo wir Spülnase, Spionagepropaganda-Samotage und Angriffe haben, einen Staat auch dort agieren muss.
Das rechtfertigt natürlich keine Massenüberwachung oder sonstige Eingriffe, die unsere Freiheitsrechte verletzen. Mehr noch. Sie sind nicht notwendig, um die Ziele zu erreichen, weil sie dem Problem nicht in Herrent,
Warum aber kommen dann solche Auswüchse und massives Fehlverhalten am Ende dabei heraus.
Meine These am Beispiel der Bundeswehr führt jetzt hoffentlich nach weitem Bogen zum Anfang zurück. Viele politisch linksdenkende Menschen lehnen Militarisierung
und Militäreinsätze im Ausland und in der Folge die Bundeswehr und militärische Strukturen ab. Endergebnis muss sein, dass bei der Bundeswehr konservativer Haltung bis hin zu Rechtsextremismus wie zuletzt wieder bekannt geworden, dominieren,
man erreicht, das Gegenteil des Ziels, die Bundeswehr verhält sich in der Tendenz noch mehr, so wie man das nicht will. Wo man selber nicht mitmacht,
da man selber nicht mitmacht. Besser scheint es mir, während die Kommandostrukturen stärker mit politisch linken Personen durchsetzt, würde das auch die Ausrichtung und das Selbstbild der Bundeswehr verändern,
kurz gesagt, im euren Fall sorgt ihr durch euer Abraten von der Arbeit für die äh Cyberwehr oder nationale Cybersicherheitsbehörden gegenüber Leuten beim CC
Klammern, die tendenziell hohe Standards für Privatsphäre und Freiheitsrechte unterstützen, dafür, dass am Ende dort Leute sitzen, die man genau nicht dort haben möchte.
Es wäre doch zur Abwechslung mal schön, wenn BND Präsident Linus Neumann erklärte.
Dass er die massenhafte Überwachung für die Strafverfolgung nicht relevant ist und deswegen abgeschafft wird,
Meine Sorge ist, das Rufen von außerhalb des Spielfeld nicht zu. Das Rufen vom.
Sorry. Meine Sorge ist, das Rufen von außerhalb des Spielfeldes nicht zum gewünschten Ergebnis führt. Besser, man macht im Prozess mit. Sonst schafft man sich,
eigenen Gegenpool. Sorry, for the Long Post. Das ist.
Ein interessanter Punkt.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, der Bewegungen natürlich oder der politische Gruppierungen immer wieder ähm beschäftigt.
Und der glaube ich auch so ein bisschen äh den seinen großen Höhepunkt hatte in der so Rudi Dutschke, dem Marsch durch die Institutionen, äh um sie dann eben von innen heraus zu verändern und es wird immer wieder ähm.
Philosophiert und gewitzelt darüber, was denn das Kräfteverhältnis ist. Ähm schaffst du es von innen heraus, die Organisation zu verändern? Ähm oder schafft es, die Organisation dich zu assimilieren.
Mein ähm ich würde prinzipiell damit rechnen, dass die Organisation,
Eher in der Lage ist nicht zu assimilieren, als du in der Lage bist sie zu verändern. Deswegen ist es eine Organisation. Also dafür werden Organisationen gebaut, dass sie dagegen resistent sind
Insbesondere bei der Bundeswehr hast du natürlich ähm relativ geringe Veränderungsmöglichkeiten. Ähm.
Als kleiner Cybersoldat oder so, ne? Ähm du kannst aber natürlich irgendwie zwanzig Jahre Karriere machen, dann bist du irgendwann Cybergeneral
Und dann kannst du vielleicht was anderes, kannst du diese Organisation verändern. Die Sorge ist eben, ob die Organisation über die zwanzig Jahre, bist du an ihre Spitze gekommen bist.
Äh dich nicht so verändert hat, dass du ähm entweder, wenn du an ihrer Spitze bist.
Im Sinne der Organisation auch handelst oder eben niemals dorthin kommst. Ne? Also so werden,
So bauen Menschen sich Organisationen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob also kann,
Auch anders laufen. Es gibt sicherlich auch Beispiele dafür. Hm, ich verstehe nur gerade bei der Bundeswehr, würde ich jetzt noch anmelden. Also ich bin,
Kriegsdienstverweigerer,
Zivildienst gemacht. Ich musste das noch machen und ich würde, ich sehe für mich jetzt persönlich bei der Bundeswehr, ich will nur ganz kurz Tim setzt schon an, ich will nur ganz kurz bei der Bundeswehr das nicht sehen, dass ich da Bock hätte zu arbeiten.
Ist auch einfach nicht meine, das ist einfach nicht die Art des Umgangs, den ich mit Menschen pflege, den man da bei der Bundeswehr hat,
auch nicht die Form von Diskussionskultur, die ich mir wünsche,
Ähm ich weiß aber zum Beispiel ähm von oder ich habe mehrere Leute im Freundeskreis, die in verschiedenen Forensik-Bereichen arbeiten. Zum Beispiel, ne? Also irgendwie für.
Im Kontext der Bundeswehr.
Nicht im Kontext der Bundeswehr. Nein, aber im Kontext der Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Mhm.
Ja, also irgendwie. Polizei, Kommissar oder äh sonst oder ähm will da jetzt nicht so.
Sagen, wo die so sitzen, aber im Inn, in der Strafverfolgung, ja? Ähm und mit denen ich, aber mit denen führe ich die besten Gespräche übrigens über ähm.
Sachen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, über so Sachen wie ähm.
Server, TKÜ oder so, ne? Das ist, das sind äh die inspirierendsten, politischen Gespräche, weil das glücklicherweise wer an dieser Stelle mal loben, äh kluge, reflektierte Leute sind, die ähm,
Das was sie tun, da äh,
Und den rechtlichen Rahmen, in dem sie agieren, sicherlich auch betrachten, aber die natürlich sich auch nicht von mir kaputtreden lassen möchten, dass sie eben den ein oder anderen ähm schwerkriminellen.
Hinter Gitter gebracht haben. Und das äh sollte man denen natürlich auch nicht,
schlecht reden. Ich wollte aber auch, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung das so ein bisschen betonen, dass selbstverständlich und das wird ja hier auch angesprochen diese Institutionen von oben oder über Jahrzehnte eben
falsch geführt und kaputt gemacht wurden. Insbesondere habe ich mich ja da über die über den Verfassungsschutz ausgelassen.
Ich finde, ähm das sind unser Kommentator hier eigentlich. Christoph. Ähm.
Christoph spricht da einen ganz interessanten Punkt an. Ich meine das, was du gesagt hast mit na ja, solche Institutionen können dich ja irgendwie ändern.
Tun sie bestimmt und also dem kann sich gar keiner entziehen. Also wenn du da natürlich wirkst, wenn das dein Umfeld ist, selbstverständlich äh äh wirst du davon geändert.
Selbstverständlich änderst du sie auch, wie das Kräfteverhältnis an der Stelle aussieht, hängt von einem selbst äh und einem bisschen natürlich auch von der Institution ab.
Gilt aber natürlich auch für Leute, die sagen wir mal mit vielleicht einer komplett anderen politischen Grundeinstellung dahin kommen. Auch die
werden natürlich dann auch und dann könnte man das eben auch positiver bewerten, ne? Also diese äh linke Angst, die er ja jetzt hier so ein bisschen anspricht mit so, wenn ich da hingehe, dann werde ich jetzt hier so ein staatstragende äh konservative Wollmilchsau äh könnte man genauso umdrehen
dass Leute, die äh potentiell so äh ja, lass mal Irak platt machen.
Und ne, auch ansonsten vielleicht nicht 'ne besonders offene Kultur und demokratisches Grundverständnis aufweisen in die Bundeswehr geraten und dort eben auch einfach mal ein anderes Bild bekommen und ich würde sogar, obwohl ich
extrem wenig Kenntnis,
über die Bundeswehr als solche habe, weil ich war da nie und hab da ehrlich gesagt nicht gesehen jetzt von einem Podcast, den ich mir drüber gemacht hab, nicht sonderlich groß mit auseinandergesetzt, aber man kann jetzt auch der Bundeswehr nicht unbedingt.
Unterstellen, dass sie in ihrer äh in dem Zeitraum ihrer Existenz sich nicht eigentlich als einen relativ solider Teil dieser demokratischen,
Grundordnung etabliert hat
So, also ich meine, klar gibt's dann immer mal wieder so ein paar wildgewordene äh Gruppen, wo was Scheiße läuft oder so. Aber grundsätzlich ist so dieses Dogma, der wir ziehen euch jetzt hier aber auch zu Grundgesetztreuen äh äh Bürgern im Sinne von wir
geben euch ja auch den entsprechenden inhaltlichen Input und wir wir stellen mal sicher auf auf welchen äh Grundlagen wir hier stehen. Ähm,
Das findet statt, so, ja? Und man man hat jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass die Bundeswehr, wie zum Beispiel der Verfassungsschutz, so ein, so ein, so ein ja, Rechts
driftender Verein ist, der äh potentiell eine große Gefahr für diese Gesellschaft darstellt,
Und insofern ist das eigentlich durchaus auch äh Debattierungswürdig, diese grundlinke äh äh Skepsis an der Stelle, zumindest in dieser Form,
ähm ja zumindest in Frage zu stellen. Weil das stimmt schon, ne, immer dieses Ablehnende, dieses,
Ah ja, Bundeswehr und da würden wir ja im Traum nicht dran denken und so weiter, ne? Kann man auch anders sehen.
Steht's steht frei.
Ja, steht euch frei. Also.
Ich habe aber auch nur dieses eine Leben und ich möchte das nicht sehen.
Nee, dass du natürlich in,
näher äh ja, aber das ist ja, sagen wir mal, äh das hat ja zwei Teile, ja? Das hat also so äh einerseits hat das was mit deiner individuellen, persönlichen Ausprägung zu tun und das gilt für mich ja genauso, also als Individualist,
kommen wir nicht so klar in solchen solchen Strukturen. Also was heißt, kommen wir nicht klar? Wir würden da äh vor die Hunde gehen, ja? Äh ich halt's ja noch nicht,
Ich halt's ja noch nicht mal in einer normalen Firma aus. Also das verstehst du, da brauchst du ja mit Bundeswehr überhaupt nichts zu kommen, weil weil ich einfach so äh bin, so,
Anderen geht das anders, ja? Viele äh haben gar nicht so ein Problem damit, so Teil eines eines Systems zu sein, sondern haben da vielleicht sogar Spaß dran.
Dass es da irgendwie eine Struktur gibt, in die man so reinflutschen kann und dann da drin seine Rolle und damit vielleicht auch seine Identifikation damit auch seine seine äh persönliche Durchsetzung der Ideale, welche auch immer das sind
ähm dadurch zu realisieren,
Insofern ähm muss man das halt ausklammern, aber dieses grundsätzlich wer links eingestellt ist, hat in der Bundeswehr nichts zu suchen,
finden kann man auch nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, also das ist glaube ich auch ein Punkt, der wahrscheinlich würde ich eher sogar sagen, wer bei der Bundeswehr ist,
Also was gilt, ist, wer bei der Bundeswehr, es hat in der linken Szene nichts zu suchen, da hast du nämlich echt Schwierigkeiten. Hm, mit so einem Militärhintergrund oder so, dass wirst du halt komisch angeguckt, ne?
Der ist aber dann ein Problem, also es ist dann eine Eigenschaft der linken Szene und.
Genau, ja, ja, genau, das ist das, was ich bemängeln möchte oder anmerken möchte.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach mehr aufeinander zugehen. Oder uns mal ein Bild malen. Wir malen einfach der Bund.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, du bei der Bundeswehr, ebenso bei beim Fußballschall. Können wir jetzt nicht auch einfach mal hier die Aussicht genießen? Ich laufe doch nicht fünfzehn Kilometer in den Wald und mache dann kein Picknick.
Nee, weiß ja, Nerz wird eine ganz andere äh Konflikte haben und so. Die argumentieren ja damit. Ja, aber warum machen wir denn das so, das ist doch jetzt nicht logisch. Ja, das kann man doch viel besser machen.
Total unsinnig. Das kann man besser so machen, dann hält das auch.
Also ich habe auch schon so einige Nerds kennengelernt, die
offene Bundeswehrkarriere durchgemacht haben, auch längere äh Karrieren, ne,
Und das ist äh teilweise auch erstaunlich, wie wie gut das eigentlich auch passt manchmal. Bei also bei den individuellen Ausprägungen, ja? Weil das sind so Leute, die sich jetzt nicht so sehr in den Vordergrund äh drängen, nicht so Egozentrika
mehr so Techniker, die sagen wir mal auch an dieser ganzen Technikpräsenz und den den manchfaltigen Ausbildungsoptionen, die man da ja hat, auch durchaus wiederfinden, da auch eine große Kompetenz aufgebaut haben und die dann eben auch so mit so einem Grund
wie sagt man? Auf den, auf den, mit den Beinen sozusagen auf der staatlichen Grundverordnung.
Wie sagt man, freie.
FDGO.
FDGO, freie deutsche Grundordnung.
Da stehen so unglücklich sind. So.
Also lieber Christoph.
Vielen Dank, dass du gedient hast.
Für uns.
Nein, es muss er auch. So, ich ich es gibt eine ganze Menge Jobs, äh die ich für die für mich nicht in Frage kommen und wo ich natürlich trotzdem froh bin, dass die.
Warum vielleicht nochmal auf die Cyberwehr auch zu erweitern, ne? So klar. Also wenn man jetzt äh nicht unbedingt äh von den Verlockungen äh des schnellen Geldes in der Privatwirtschaft äh wenn einem das nicht,
so viel Wert zu sein scheint, was ich auch nachvollziehen könnte,
Ja und wenn man da auch vielleicht einfach so ein ähm mit dem mit dem gebotenen staatlichen äh Grundvertrauen einfach bereit ist, an an der Stelle zu wirken.
Warum nicht? Ja? Äh die Frage ist halt nur ähm begibt man sich nicht dann eben äh zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt auch genau in,
äh in in solche Konfliktlinien äh rein, wo dann eben die Freiheitsgrundrechte äh äh verletzt werden.
Das ist ja diese ganze Trojaner und und Security-Debatte, die wir schon geführt haben, ne, wenn du halt im Cyberkrieg dein Arsenal aufbauen willst, dann,
Na ja, dann dann schränkt es halt potentiell
die Sicherheit aller ein, das ist zumindest die Debatte, wie sie derzeit geführt werden muss, weil das das einfach mal die Realität äh ist. Vielleicht ändert sich das, vielleicht ähm
schafft es auch da die äh Cyberwehr sich da eine andere Grundlage zu verpassen und zu sagen
Wir sorgen einfach mal nur für Kompetenz und und Handlungsoptionen und Infrastrukturen. Melden diese Systeme und andere Maßnahmen ohne jetzt auf dieses dünne Eis uns zu begeben, das wird quasi Angriffskriege
digitaler Natur führen, die einfach darauf basieren, dass wir eben die Sicherheit für alle reduzieren. Wäre schön, ja? Wäre schön.
Aber also um nochmal ganz kurz den Eindruck hier, was einen da bei der Cybereinheit erwartet. Dominik,
Hagener vom Bundeswehrkarrierecenter. Äh wir zitiert mit. Das sind ja keine Nerds, die Cola trinkend und Chips essen nächtelang vor dem Rechner sitzen.
Also das finde ich gut, diese Warnung, das weiß sonst wäre es vielleicht echt noch attraktiv gewes.
Dass er auch verpasste Chance.
Dass ich glaube, da müsste man ja da sollte man nochmal die Strategie überdenken, ob man nicht genau das den Leuten anbieten würde.
Genau. Unlimited Flatrate so, Cola Chips, Flatrate.
Ähm so dann.
Ah ja genau, dann hatte ich am am vor der letzten Sendung habe ich dann noch den habe ich den Arne Bense angeschrieben,
und hab gesagt, wir müssten, wir bräuchten eigentlich einen Cybermarsch und habe geschrieben, ich habe die das nachher auch veröffentlicht, diesen kurzen Austausch, ich habe geschrieben
Morgens um elf, das war also eine Stunde vor der Einweihung dieses Cyber-Commer, das habe ich gesagt, so einen Cybermarsch. Bevor die ihren eigenen machen
Und Anel antwortet nur mit Dur oder Moll. Und ich habe da dir wie gesagt, ich dachte an sowas Bekanntes äh wie irgendein Lied. Aber das muss jetzt auch nicht sofort sein. Kongress würde wahrscheinlich reichen
Und ähm um einundzwanzig Uhr dreizehn guckte ich dann die Tagesschau. Ähm also im im Stream und.
Fucking Hell. Ich wollte es nicht glauben, die haben einen Cybermarsch, denn es wurde mit einem Cybermarsch dieses Kommando eingeweiht,
Und es gibt also jetzt einen offiziellen Cybermarsch. Wir haben ja noch an unsere letzte Sendung in so einer anderen Bundeswehrmarsch dran gehängt, den wir äh den wir amüsant fanden. Aber.
Es gibt den Cybermarsch. Man kann den auch irgendwie kaufen, aber Anna Bizelli hat jetzt mal eine Informationsfreiheitsanfrage gestellt,
Weil das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass äh wir bezahlen müssen für den Cyber-Marsch,
Marsch des Kommando CIR. Komponiert von Sebastian Mittel und arrangiert von Guido Rennert. Ähm da ist auch das Logo drauf, was jetzt ich,
Da gab's schon gelungenere. Aber es gibt einen Cybermarsch und ähm so oft stehen wir dann doch als Satiriker,
was erstaunt vor der Realität, die uns alle Witze wegnimmt.
Haudeo.
So das noch als Nachtrag dann gab es die äh die Deklaration für die Meinungsfreiheit ist in der letzten Woche.
Ähm dann auch noch Vernehe in dieser Woche am Dienstag veröffentlicht worden. Ähm in Deutsch und in Englischer Sprache ähm.
Und zwar einem ein länglicher Text, der sich primär auf den Richtervorbehalt konzentriert und sagt, es kann nicht so gehen.
Wie mit dem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz vorgeschlagen, dass Unternehmen einen sehr großen,
Anreiz haben einen Strafanreiz haben, ähm Inhalte im Zweifelsfall zu löschen.
Und keinen großen Strafeinreiz haben oder keine große Strafe befürchten, wenn sie Inhalte fälschlicherweise löschen. Denn offiziell prinzipiell verlangt das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ja nur das illegale Inhalte,
oder strafrechtlich relevante Inhalte gelöscht werden, aber die Meinungsfreiheit ist ja genau an diesem Übergang
zwischen äh strafrechtlich relevant und nicht. Und genau da in diesem Graubereich ist die Tendenz. Der ist natürlich in die Richtung des Löschens. Das ist die der Kern.
Ähm der Kernpunkt ähm der Deklaration für meines Falls, die noch sehr viel länger ist. Und die wurde von sehr vielen Organisationen
unterzeichnet, unter anderem der Amadeo Antonio Stiftung, was interessant ist, weil die ja ein, eine der primären oder eine der Hauptorganisationen ist, die sich im Moment irgendwie gegen das Phänomen der Hassrede im Netz
stellen, ja? Also genau, sogar die sagen, dass so nicht. Ähm der Bitcoin-Brancheverband der IT und Kommunikationsunternehmen dann ähm.
Der BVDW Bundesverband digitale Wirtschaft, Bundesverband IT-Mittelstand C-Netz sogar, ja? Also der der netzpolitische Verein der CDU nahe, netzpolitische Verein,
B vierundsechzig der SPD nahe netzpolitische Verein, digitale Gesellschaft, Chaos, Computerclub, natürlich ähm.
Ekoverband der Internetwirtschaft. Die freiwillige Selbstkontrolle, Multimedia, also Reporter ohne Grenzen, Wikimedia Openolisch fand ich alle, alle dagegen. Ähm es dauerte dann auch, glaube ich, keine.
Keine keinen halben Tag bis wir eine ähm eine Einladung des Staatssekretärs bekamen,
ähm doch mal über dieses Thema zu sprechen, weil man im Bundesjustizministerium dann auch ein bisschen traurig ist, dass äh,
dass man sich da wieder was Schönes ausgedacht hat und alle äh mal wieder dagegen sind. Und da werden wird also ein Treffen stattfinden, dann werden wir da ähm.
Mal schauen, ob wir dieses Gesetz nicht in irgendeiner Form nochmal äh sinnvoll verbessern können.
Ja, das ist ja auch für dich ein Drama und das ist ja auch, wie sich das abgezeichnet hat, ist das ja auch so ein totaler Unfall. Also wieder mal so ein richtiger Organisatorischer Fuckup und äh jetzt stellen sie auf einmal fest, so oh hola,
CDU eigene Institutionen stellen sich, stellen sich dagegen irgendwie, also das das muss man sich auch echt mal einrahmen hier irgendwie so CC und C-Netz irgendwie nebeneinander.
Ja, also.
Wenn wir so oft nicht sehen, glaube ich.
Das wird so oft nicht passieren. Ähm entsprechend vorsichtig war auch die Anfrage von Volker Tripp, ob der CC das mitzeichnet. Äh so, also Volker Trip, digitale Gesellschaft.
Hier ja auch schon zu Gast gew.
Ja dann so sagte sie, ja aber ihr müsst natürlich auch also das ist auch kein Problem für euch, wenn da nein, natürlich nicht. Also ich habe das vor vor vielen, vielen Jahren mal ähm.
Gesagt, dass es den halte ich immer noch für einen meiner,
also einen der Sprüche, die ich mir gemerkt habe, ich kloppe ja eine Menge. Aber den habe ich mir gemerkt, mir ist das völlig egal, wer am Ende das Richtige tut, ja. Hauptsache, das geschieht. Und ähm dann bin ich natürlich auch, das kann von mir aus auch gerne die CDU tun. Ähm.
Wir spielen auch mit Schmuddelkindern.
So kurzer Schluck für meine Stimme.
Aus dem großen Bierglas. Mit Wasser drin.
Mit Wasser drin. Ja, Tim, es ist auch schon verdächtig, dass du hier nur Biergläser und Kaffeetassen hast. Du hast kein normales Glas.
Früh am Morgen. Wie nur stimmt gar nicht? Ein normales Glas. Das stimmt nicht. Die sind nur nicht äh ab sind nur nicht abgewaschen.
Ja
Ja, ich musste nochmal über.
Müsste nochmal irgendwann spülen die Tage. So jetzt ähm jetzt kommt endlich das Thema, was wir sind eigentlich immer noch bei der bei der Aufarbeitung der letzten Woche.
Ja, sind wir und ähm was auch noch aufgearbeitet werden muss, ist äh Stream on.
Aber da müssen wir auch zu unserer Entschuldigung sagen, dass wir haben das Thema äh nicht korrekt behandelt, aber es war auch gerade erst äh gebrochen. Das Thema war noch,
zu frisch und es gab noch nicht die Informationen, die wir euch jetzt äh in aller Ruhe dazu kredenzen würden.
Ich sag aber auch gleich mal dazu. Ich habe so ein bisschen meine,
Zweifel, wie akkurat wir das jetzt äh treffen werden. Weißt du, ist es schon so ein bisschen verwirrend? Also muss nochmal zurückzuspulen.
Es gibt jetzt ein neues Angebot der Telekom im Mobilfunkbereich und zwar äh gibt's diese Stream on,
Option oder Tarife, wo das sozusagen mit ähm dabei ist, in ihrem Magenta L hast du nicht gesehen, äh Tarifen,
und na ja in der Werbesprache ist das dann äh schön blumig mit hier Video unbegrenzt, alles geil. Ähm
Musik und Audio, was was will man mehr im Internet als die ganze Zeit Fernsehen zugucken? Ist doch das schönste überhaupt und wenn ihr das halt bei uns dann äh klickt, dann kommt das irgendwie alles unbegrenzt im Sinne von euer Datenvolumen,
wird hier nicht aufgebraucht und dann leuchteten natürlich sofort die Netzneutralitätsalarmglocken auf,
wenn Alarmglocken aufleuchten. Die Warnlampen haben aufgeleuchtet. Die Glocken haben geläutet
und äh es steht so ein bisschen der Verdacht im Raum, dass es sich hierbei unter Umständen, um eine Verletzung der Netzneutralität, so wie sie ja nun zuletzt im EU-Parlament beschlossen wurde, handeln könnte.
Jetzt,
Ist es so ein bisschen schwierig, das muss man sich mal angucken, was wird denn dann eigentlich jetzt wirklich getan? So und auf auf welche Art und Weise. Und so wie sich das jetzt uns oder mir zumindest jetzt gerade darstellt, sieht das folgendermaßen aus.
Die Tilo gesagt.
Na ja, ihr wollt ja viel Video gucken. Ist schon geil, aber ähm na ja, mit diesem ganzen HD äh äh Videodatenmengen, das belastet unser Netz ja so unglaublich und das ist ja alles so unheimlich teuer.
Machen wir doch einen Deal und wenn ihr über diesen Tarif ins Netz geht, dann gibt's schon Video.
Aber wir reduzieren das mal in der Qualität. Das heißt, da ist so so eine generelle Drossel.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist das halt einfach auch generell eigentlich so eine Datendrossel, weil man am Ende halt nicht wirklich weiß, was da für Daten übertragen werden, kommen wir auch gleich nochmal dazu.
Man kriegt also erstmal so ein, so einen generell so einen gedrosselten äh Tarif und dann ist man aber so,
Ah okay, also ihr wollt uns jetzt hier einen Trottelvertrag verkaufen und das Video ist es schlechter.
Wir müssen ganz kurz erklären, ähm kleiner Exkurs Videodrossel, warum geht? Warum kann man ein Video drosseln und es wird dann in der Qualität schlechter. Sonst wundern sich die Leute jetzt.
Ja, ich meine, also gedrosselt wird die Geschwindigkeit mit der äh die Daten zu einem durchgeleitet werden.
Und dann gibt es eine Technik, die nennt sich adaptive Bitrate, das ist nämlich dann der Server und der kleinen merken, dass sie.
Kriegen die Daten hier nicht schneller durch, also schicken wir dann mal die Variante dieses Videos, was halt nicht so toll in.
Und dann gehen sie dann dann entscheidet sich der Server quasi automatisch automatisch in der Absprache mit dem Kleinfall, da merkten mehr eine schnellere Verbindung kriegen wir nicht hin.
Genau und damit sozusagen der Real Time Effekt nicht abreißt, ja?
Gehen wir auf eine niedrigere Bandbreite, also ein schlechter kodiertes Video hat man, sieht man vielleicht auch öfter mal, wenn man wirklich mal unterwegs irgendwie ein YouTube-Video guckt, dass dann,
Unter bestimmten Bedingungen halt einfach das Video in seiner Qualität einfach total schlecht wird. Ne, YouTube macht das sehr, sehr gut. Die gehen geben es dem Notfall wirklich in in bis zur Unkenntlichkeit, komprimierter ähm,
Form, Hauptsache das Video kommt und läuft durch, ne? Und die.
Ja und vor allem Audio Audio ist halt auch immer wichtig, ne? Also Audio muss sozusagen erhalten bleiben, weil wenn Audio stockt, dann stört es sofort, wenn ein Video mal schlechter wird, dann kann man damit noch halbwegs äh äh leben, ist nicht schön, aber geht. Genau. So, also es heißt.
Das heißt, technisch muss die Telekom nur, kann einfach nur die, die Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit reduzieren.
Und schon kommt alles in schlechterer Qualität.
Und schon wird es bei den meisten Anbietern, die irgendwie halbwegs aktuelle Technik äh im einen im Anhaltspunkt im Einsatz haben, wird dann die Qualität einfach entsprechend des Videos angepasst.
Das heißt aber auch wiederum, wenn man Videos.
In guter Qualität anbietet, aber nicht in schlechterer Qualität auch noch und vor allem nicht die Technik für diese adaptive äh Auslieferung am Start hat. Äh dann.
Führt es einfach dazu, dass man dieses Video gar nicht anschauen kann. Das äh auch noch so ein Abfallprodukt. Kommen wir gleich nochmal dazu. Wenn wir uns anschauen, wie das Ganze jetzt technisch realisiert ist. So, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ja geiler Dienst, also alles erstmal in schlecht.
Und dann argumentiert die Telekom so, na ja ähm.
Mag jetzt vielleicht nicht so heires sein alles, aber wir wissen ja aus welchen Quellen hier Video kommt
Und dann geben wir euch den Deal, dass das Video, was dann halt so runtergedrosselt ist, dass das eben überhaupt nicht auf das Datenvolumen angerechnet wird und von daher könnt ihr dann aber auch wirklich äh die Scheiße gucken, in Scheiße Qualität, bis der Arzt kommt.
Und der, der, der
die Kalkulation dahinter, Tim und ich haben hier gerade mal den Taschenrechner gezückt. Ähm ist, dass sie ungefähr,
in dieser Qualität, die sie da anstreben. Ein Viertel der des Daten der Datenbandbreite brauchen die das Video normalerweise hätte.
Genau, also hier managed May very, aber so so HD, so richtig Full HD Video kommt so mit irgendwie vier bis fünf Megabit daher. Das hängt natürlich dann auch mal noch vom Anbieter da. Da sind jetzt noch ein paar YouTube-Zahlen, die wir mal genommen haben.
Und ähm für die äh von der Telekom postulierte DVD-Qualität, was man jetzt mal als äh vierachtzig P Video äh interpretieren möchten. Es ist halt ungefähr fünfundzwanzig Prozent davon,
Natürlich kann man auch die Bitrate eines.
HD Videos noch runtersetzen und die Qualität des Videos selber äh schlechter machen, obwohl noch mehr äh Pixel auf den Screen geworfen werden, aber das.
Hast aber nichts von.
Äh läuft hat man nichts von, ist am Ende vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen schlechter.
Der Unsinn, ja.
Jetzt stellt sich halt die Frage, gut, wenn die Telekom jetzt quasi als Gegendeal sagt, das schlechtere Video, was kommt,
koste ich zumindest nichts, also geht nicht von deinem Datenvolumen ab, sodass nicht dann irgendwann alles äh komplett ausgeschaltet wird oder auf so eine niedrige Drossel gesetzt wird,
Das gar nichts mehr geht ähm und wenn man das mal so sieht, wir reden hier wahrscheinlich von so einer Drossel um so ein mega Bitter rum oder so oder ein, zwei Megabit.
Tan steht eins Komma sieben, das habe ich aber den Teil habe ich gerade in AGBs nicht gefunden, aber wir haben einen Kommentar gehalten, bekommen wo drin steht. Alle Videos hier werden auf eins Komma sieben MB gedrosselt.
Macht, macht
ne? Also so eins Komma eins eins Komma zwei braucht man auch wirklich. Dann hast du noch ein bisschen Overhead und dann noch Cover und HDML drumherum und Pipapo, die Werbung muss ja auch noch laden. Also da hat man dann so ein bisschen Headroom, aber
du brauchst schon für die nächste Qualitätsstufe so siebenundzwanzig P brauchst du dann halt auch schon mal so zwei Megabit, also das scheint so ein ganz gutes Tage zu sein,
Das heißt, sie können davon ausgehen, dass selbst wenn die Leute den ganzen Tag nichts anderes machen, als YouTube zu gucken, ähm da einfach nur so ein konstanter Datenregen von maximal eins Komma fünf Megabit äh sich äh entfaltet
und offenbar ist das eine Größenordnung, wo die Telekom der Meinung ist, das kriegt ihr Netz einfach so her. Zumal es ja auch,
ähm eine Frage ist, wo sie eigentlich das Bottleg äh sehen und wofür sie eigentlich wirklich Kosten entstehen, weil die großen Videoanbieter, wo die allermeisten Daten herkommen, also YouTube vor allem,
Sind ja ohnehin direkt an das Telekom-Netz angeboten, das heißt, da entstehen keine Durchleistungs äh Durchleitungskosten, ganz im Gegenteil, teilweise lässt sich die Telekom sowas ja auch noch gerne bezahlen.
Und äh auf der anderen Seite im Mobilfunkbereich hat man natürlich dann immer noch so die Bandbreitenreduktion ähm durch die durch die Netze selber, wobei das eben jetzt im Ausbau von LTE auch
zunehmenden Maße unproblematischer sein dürfte. Also es führt auch mal grundsätzlich ein bisschen Zweifel anbieten. Kommen wir jetzt zu der Sache mit der.
Freistellung vom Tarif. Wie machen die denn das?
Ich würde noch ganz kurz einen einen Punkt sagen, also die die Mischkalkulation, die der Telekom hier zugrunde liegt oder diese Überlegung zu Grunde Licht ist. Wir können das, was bei uns Video ist, um bis zu äh fünfundsiebzig Prozent reduzieren.
Ja
wie gesagt, das kann auch sein, vielleicht gucken einige Leute sowieso erst die wie das, aber sie sagen, wir machen diesen ganzen HD-Kram weg, den eliminieren wir und können damit diesen Teil, der uns Kopfschmerzen macht, um auf ein Viertel eindampfen
Und das wird natürlich der Effekt, dass die Leute dann vielleicht sagen, oh geil, jetzt kann ich mehr Video gucken. Die werden nicht vier werden im im,
in der Masse nicht zu einer Vervierfachung führen. Das heißt, sie sparen am Ende Last auf ihrem Netz,
Ja, also sie können sie komprimieren diese oder sie erzwingen die Videos langsamer und schlechter zu sein als zu erwarten ist, dass die Leute sie mehr gucken. Das heißt, ähm wir haben gerade im Vorgespräch festgestellt, die
Die Optimierungsdimension ist quasi entweder die für den Kunden ist das die Nettominute Video die der Kunde sehen kann.
Und für die Telekom ist es aber, sage ich mal, dass,
Datenvolumen und der Daten äh der Datendurchsatz in Video, der sich eben ganz, ganz massiv einschränken lässt. Und das ist ihnen quasi sogar wert, den dann lieber gar nicht mehr zu berechnen.
Um es somit dann auch noch attraktiv für die Kunden zu machen.
Muss ich schon die Frage stellen, warum es jetzt eigentlich bei so einer Drosselung auf eins Komma sieben Megabit überhaupt noch,
eine Volumenbegrenzung gibt, ne? Also O2 hat ja zum Beispiel ein Tarif, wo sie sagen, hier unlimited alles an Limited, äh ein Megabit.
Das ist dann für so richtig Online-Video in brauchbarer Qualität gucken, auch nicht so geil, da kriegst du also noch nicht mal deine vier achtzig P, sondern kriegst du halt eher so die drei sechziger Variante, also oder weniger oder zwei vierzig P.
Das was so die schlechteren Qualitäten äh sind,
Aber immerhin einen Tarif, wo du auch weißt, mir das geht mir nicht komplett weg. Ne, also du hast.
Das hast du zumindest auch immer und du musst dir keine Gedanken mehr darüber machen äh das irgendwann dein Internet alle ist. So und mit Megabit kann man ja zumindest immer noch kommunizieren, da kannst du immer noch Sachen verschicken, kannst Sachen noch hoch und runterladen, dauert dann halt länger.
Du kannst chatten, äh was für viele Leute eine wichtige Sache ist. Du bist einfach nicht so so generell abgeschnitten. Und das finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt
jetzt bei diesem Tarif auch schon so ein bisschen fragwürdig, ja? Reden wir nicht schon langsam von der Kapazität, wo äh so ein, so ein, so ein Netzset Telekom ohnehin mitmachen müsst. Aber
nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal zur Kenntnis, dass die Telekom der Meinung ist, das wäre für sie ein Problem und sie müssten da nach wie vor so eine Datenvolumengrenze ziehen,
und jetzt sagen sie halt, na ja okay, alles klar, wir haben zwar Limitierungen, aber für die populären Videosachen äh nehmen wir das jetzt mal raus. Wie nehmen sie das dann raus,
Jetzt ist ja immer so eine Befürchtung dieser ganzen Netzneutralitätsdiskussionen gewesen.
Wenn die hier unterscheiden wollen, was für Inhalte übermittelt werden, dann müssen sie da tief reinschauen. Das läuft unter dem Stichwort Depacket Inspection.
Wobei der ursprüngliche Begriff der Depacket Inspection halt auch so wirklich, wo das Dieb wirklich so eine Rolle äh spielt. Also eine eine Packetinspection,
Findet ja ohnehin statt, also in dem Moment, wo man Paket nimmt, muss man jetzt gucken, wo will das hin, wo wird das hingerotet, et cetera, also man muss sich ja die Pakete auch anschauen, um sie weiterleiten zu können. Die Frage ist nur, wie gut muss man sie sich angucken und das Dieb
beinhaltet sozusagen, wir schauen auf die Inhalte. Im Sinne von.
Bei Überwachungsmaßnahmen, bei Zensurmaßnahmen äh bedeutet die Inspection halt im Idealfall. Wir schauen richtig in den Datenstrom selber rein und versuchen irgendwie Erkenntnisse darüber zu gewinnen,
Im Falle eines Netzwerkbetreibers ist es, wir schauen tiefer rein, als das äh IP-Protokoll jetzt ähm,
äh normalerweise es erforderlich machen würde, nur um den eigentlichen Kernbetrieb aufrecht zu erhalten, weil jetzt wollen wir ja Dienste unterscheiden und das müssen wir anhand von irgendetwas tun.
Also die das IP-Paket kommt und das steht vorne dran, kann man sich auch sehr schön beim Internet äh oder kann man sich auch in Büchern anschauen, wie so ein IP-Paket aussieht. Steht vorne irgendwie dran, wo es herkommt, wo es hin will
Und für den Router ist eigentlich nichts weiteres entscheidend, ne? Man muss einfach nur sagen, okay
ähm zu dieser IP-Adresse geht es bei mir da lang. Und wenn man aber jetzt sagt, was wird denn da eigentlich übertragen.
Ähm also ab dem Moment, wo man in dem Bereich schaut, der nicht mehr Routing relevant ist. Ähm sprich man also von,
die Packet-Inspection.
Also fängt schon mal bei den Ports irgendwie an, ist auch nicht Routing äh relevant, sondern das ist ja nur so eine, so eine Information, die am Schluss noch mit.
Na, das das ist aber noch so ein bisschen steht das am Schluss, ne? Das steht im Head.
Lassen wir kurz kurz mal äh erläutern. Also,
wie kann die Telekom das jetzt überhaupt unterscheiden? Und ihr Modell, was sie jetzt gewählt haben, ist äh liebe Provider, ihr kennt ja sicherlich unseren geilen Stream-On-Dienst.
Da wir überhaupt die wichtigsten und die Geilsten sind hier in Deutschland. Müssen ja jetzt auch alle mitspielen. Hier ist äh ein schönes Excel-Formular, da tragt ihr mal äh bitte ein, wo wir über weitere technische Details mit euch reden können.
Wenn ihr möchtet, dass ihr in der.
Genau, weil der das Ding ist ja, man man in dem Moment, wo ein Kunde diesen Tarif wählt,
ist das Video scheiße, weil die Drossel ist aktiv. Jetzt kann man aber noch sozusagen mitspielen und sagen, na ja, jetzt möchten wir aber den Leuten nicht in die Tasche äh auf die Tasche gehen und nicht noch dieses Datenvolumen,
hochtreiben, was dort verbraucht wird. Also melden wir uns da einfach mal an,
Und sagen, ja hier, wir sind so ein geiler Videodienst und äh hier liebe Telekom, habt ihr technische Informationen anhand ihr, die äh anhand derer ihr unsere Videostreams erkennen könnt,
das sind dann so Sachen wie Absende, IP-Adressen,
oder eben dann auch bestimmte Ports, die man dann verwenden muss, teilweise wohl auch. Das richtig verstanden habe,
Die Telekom sagt, dann können wir das leichter unterscheiden. So, wenn ihr das über uns schickt, dann macht ihr nimmt ihr so bestimmte Port Ranges oder aber es geht dann soweit und jetzt kommen wir auch so in so einen kritischen Bereich.
In dem Moment, wo hat die PS verwendet wird, was ja glücklicherweise im zunehmenden Maße geschieht. Wenn nicht sogar schon mehrheitlich, dann kann man ja mit dieser Depacket-Inspektion in die eigentlichen Daten gar nicht mehr reinschauen, aber man kann so,
die Oberfläche davon, die Kryptooberfläche davon sehen, also die Informationen, die man braucht, um dann äh auf der anderen Seite zu entschlüsseln, sprich man kann die Zertifikate äh sehen und andere Domaininformationen.
Also hier würden sie auf die Servername-Identifikation gehen, also wo quasi noch einmal zu Beginn der verschlüsselten Verbindung unverschlüsselt der Client sagt,
Ich möchte mit diesem Host hier reden, ja? Es ist deshalb notwendig, weil ähm unter vielen IP-Adressen ja viele verschiedene Domains gehostet sind. Wenn jetzt irgendwie eine IP-Adresse hast und da sind aber zwei Domains drauf, ne? Irgendwie sagen wir mal hier ähm,
Meterebene, ME und Logbuch Netzpolitik DE zum Beispiel sind beide auf einer IP. Jetzt kommt der Client und sagt zu dem Server, hallo, ich möchte,
Von dir Inhalte runterladen? Ich möchte verschlüsseln und dann sagt er, dann sagt er und dann nehmen wir doch mal das Zertifikat für Logbuch Netzpolitik DE
Und in diesem Moment weiß der Server, welches Zertifikat er benutzen soll, welches Zertifikat der Client erwartet und dann wird verschlüsselt, aber dieser Teil, das,
ähm dass ihr quasi Lokbuch Netzpolitik DE besucht und nicht was weiß ich, Freakshow FM. Ähm der ist dann immer noch,
unverschlüsselt, erkennbar anhand der äh SNI. Und darauf würde die Telekom dann schauen und da sind wir dann in dem Bereich der wirklich dann eben,
Inhalt des IP-Paketes ist.
Genau, also da da geht's zumindest los, da
kommen wir dann auch gleich nochmal dran. Also das ist sozusagen das Ding. Sprich wir reden hier von einem Modell, wo jetzt alle äh großen oder auch kleinen Anbieter äh freiwillig zur Telekom laden und sagen, hier äh wir beschließen mit euch einen Vertrag. Das ist äh im Übrigen dann so, man akzeptiert da halt
Geschäftsbedingungen, da sind dann auch Strafzölle mit drin, wenn man sich irgendwie falsch verhält. Auf einmal bietet man irgendwas anders an, dann kann man da irgendwie bis zu fünfzigtausend Euro.
Ja Schaden erleiden oder Haftstrafen auferleg
bekommen, äh das ist also auch schon mal so ein Schritt, das heißt in dem Moment, wo man sich eben der Telekom gegenüber offenbart und sagt, ja hier, äh, wir möchten nicht mitverantwortlich sein, damit eure äh Kunden, euer, ihr Datenvolumen verbrauchen, da wird man ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht zu gezwungen, weil, was hab ich mit den Verträgen, mit den Kundenverträgen der Telekom zu tun, ja? Also
ARD und ZDF spielen da jetzt mit, reden wir auch gleich nochmal drüber, äh, so nach dem Motto, nur in der Angst, weil
Ja, wir wollen ja nicht, dass wir dafür Kosten verantwortlich sind, aber das sind ja Kosten, die die Telekom ihren Kunden auferlegt, das ist ja nicht die Schuld von ARD und ZDF. Also da ist so ein bisschen ein vorauseilender äh Gehorsam, der eigentlich nie ähm erforderlich gewesen wäre
der hier jetzt betrieben wird. Aber führen wir dann mal dieses Angebot als solches noch zu Ende ähm.
Jetzt gibt es also eine eine ganze Reihe von Anbietern, die dann bei der Telekom aufgeschlagen sind, gesagt haben, ja hier IP-Adresse, Zertifikate, bestimmte Port Ranges äh et cetera. Wir kennen uns doch,
Diese Information wird dann im Telekom-Netzwerk hinterlegt und wann auch immer halt dort einen Videostream oder Audiostream abgerufen wird,
der bekannten Merkmalen entspricht, dann fällt das halt aus der Tarifierung raus und dann kann man davon eben beliebig viel machen,
Das ist dann eben nicht der gesamte Traffic, der von YouTube kommt, sondern dass es sozusagen das Video, aber der ganze Chrome drumherum, die ganzen äh lustigen äh Hasskommentare, die man auch dazu geliefert bekommt, die schlagen halt nach wie vor auf die Uhr auf, gut, das mag jetzt nicht so viel sein.
Aber es geht sozusagen nicht um alles, was YouTube ist, sondern es geht tatsächlich explizit nur um diese Videoströme und nur die werden dann äh,
halt in sehr schlechten Qualität ausgeliefert, wobei auch alles andere lädt nicht schneller, ja? Also auch eure HC Mehl Seiten unterliegen diesem Limit, denn das können sie halt nicht wirklich unterscheiden, weil sie können zwar, sie wissen zwar,
von ausgewählten Anbietern was davon ein Video oder Audiostream ist.
Aber sie wissen nicht automatisch von allem anderen, dass es das nicht ist, weil sowas wie Media CC DE wird ein Scheißtun mit der Telekom
da ja blöde AGBs unter äh schreiten und wenn halt dort ein Streaming stattfindet, was nicht adaptiv ist, dann bedeutet das schlicht und ergreifend, dass man über diesen Tarif halt kein HD Video da gucken kann
weil kann da nicht unterschieden werden, ist gedrosselt
Server kann nicht auf eine schlechtere Version zurückschalten, weil's vielleicht technisch äh so nicht da ist und ja, musste langsam runterladen auf dein Gerät und darfst es dir dann anschauen, wenn er alles fertig ist und das dauert dann unter Umständen halt doppelt so lange.
Gedauert hätte, als wenn man sich das Video in Echtzeit anschaut.
Und da bin ich mir aber irgendwie nicht so sicher, ob das da wirklich steht. Also man.
Na, wie willst du denn das sonst unterscheiden? Ich meine, wenn sie da an der Stelle sagen, ja, hier Fullspeed ahad, äh dann gäb's ja äh diese Drossel nicht und dann gibt's auch keine Notwendigkeit, da irgendwas zu unterschreiben. Es geht halt aufs Datenvolumen.
Darum muss ich halt eigentlich auch noch fragen, ist halt so ein Datenvolumen, vor allem so ein niedriges Datenvolumen, überhaupt noch zeitgemäß. Meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber die also ich war die Frage ist, drosseln sie wirklich alles andere als Videostreams auch. Im Zweifelsfall ja.
Ja, müssen sie, also sonst ist äh äh sonst hätten ja die anderen gesagt, ja, wir wir schicken einfach mal schlechtere Qualität und äh die anderen schicken in besserer Qualität, das kann ja nur ordentlich das Ding sein. Man will ja eigentlich.
Doch, der ist entscheidend, ist doch das Anrechnen aufs Datenvolumen.
Das ist nur entscheidend für den Kunden, das Verhältnis der Telekom zu den Kunden, dass es mir doch als Videoanbieter ist es auch vollkommen egal.
Nee, das ist äh das ist doch der also die Telekom. Ich interpretiere das so. Das Problem Videocontent von Nicht-Video-Content zu unterscheiden, haben sie.
Und zwar massiv, ja? Ähm.
Aber der Anbieter hat doch ja.
Das Problem haben sie. Gleichzeitig gibt es aber nur ganz wenige ähm Anbieter, die ihnen den großen Teil des Traffics machen. Also YouTube von mir aus dann noch hier Tagesschau, Netflix, so die großen Videohoster.
Für den Rest ist ihnen der Aufwand eigentlich auch scheißegal, weil ihnen, weil ihnen das nicht so, weil sie das nicht so schwer ins Markt trifft. Jetzt sagen sie einfach, okay, wir möchten aber gerne, dass einfach bei allen machen,
Und wir müssen's auch bei allen machen, damit wir nicht einen auf den Sack kriegen wegen Netzneutralität.
Also sagen wir, okay, wenn wir das, wenn ihr darunter fallen wollt, dann müsst ihr uns aber wenigstens dabei helfen, euch zu erkennen
Und ich glaube, das ist quasi diese dieses, auch wenn du dir anschaust, was du da an an Excel-Tabelle ausfüllen musst für was in den AGB steht, sind im Prinzip wirklich,
nur technische Details oder technische Anweisungen, die es denen ermöglichen, Video.
Von dir und nur Video von dir zu erkennen. Ja, sagen zum Beispiel das Preview JPG, was äh äh erst angezeigt wird. Das muss von einer von einer anderen Stelle kommen und muss sich von dem Videostream unterscheiden,
So, ähm dafür und diese Information wollen sie haben und ich ähm.
Da sie die sonst nicht bekommen würden, glaube ich, dass sie sagen, okay, da damit alle Anbieter mitmachen,
geben wir dem ganzen Ding dieses dieses noch dazu. Und ich glaube, dass was die wirklich machen wollen ist ähm.
Die allgemeine die die Nettominute Video, die sie mit ihrem alten Netz durchgeprügelt kriegen
erhöhen, die Anzahl Nettominuten erhöhen und sie kombinieren's mit Sirating, damit Ihnen nämlich nicht einfach wenn das Everating Angebot nicht wäre, würde man ganz einfach dazu sagen,
ist eine Drossel fertig,
Ist auch eine Drosse und sie waren seit jetzt, sie sagen halt dann, okay, dann nehmen wir noch Zero-Wating mit dazu, damit die Leute das schlucken, damit die Anbieter.
Einen offenbar kostenlosen Vorteil darin sehen uns das zu ermöglichen, was wir selber so nicht hinkriegen und auch politisch nicht verkauft äh äh an die Kunden nicht verkauft bekommen hätten.
Aber ich habe doch kein Interesse daran. Ich habe doch kein Interesse daran, meinen Kunden schlechteres Video auszuliefern.
Das hast du vielleicht nicht Tim, aber das, deswegen lieferst du auch relativ wenig Video aus. Ähm.
YouTube, wenn ich YouTube bin, habe ich doch kein Interesse daran, dass schlechtes Video bei meinem Kunden landet. Ich will doch die bestmögliche Qualität abliefern.
Der Traffic interessiert auch YouTube einen Scheiß mit ihren Netzen, aber sämtliche Videos, die sie da einblenden als Werbung.
Wenn wenn sie quasi ihren Werbekunden erzählen müssen, übrigens eure geilen hochproduzierten Full HD,
knackige Farben, geil produziert, teure Produktion, wir nehmen eine Menge Geld dafür. Äh Videos werden jetzt hier einfach mal alle äh in Scheißqualität ausgeliefert, das ist doch kein Argument,
gerade Werbung ist ja bei diesen Videoportalen im zunehmenden Maße auch ein Faktor und natürlich geht's da äh auch um um um Qualität. Also ich kann das nicht sehen, dass YouTube.
Jetzt irgendwie das geil finden soll, dass sie gedrosselt werden
Nur weil die Telekom nicht in der Lage ist, das notwendige Datenvolumen an ihre Kunden aus äh zu liefern. Für YouTube ist es am besten, wenn einfach,
Was auch immer sie meinen, was das Beste ist und wie sie's äh im Netz haben will, überall zu empfangen ist. Für sie ist auch so ein Mobilkunde
genauso wie jemand der zu Hause an seinem DSL am Desktop sitzt und der ja auch die volle Qualität bekommt. Den schicken sie ja auch nicht nur schlechtere Qualität, weil sie das für eine tolle Idee halten und weil sie dann irgendwie weniger Trafficverbrauch auf äh seiner Leitung ist, was er unter Umständen auch noch existiert. Also.
Existiert ja auch nur für den Mobilfunk. Es gibt ja jetzt nicht für diese
O zwei Drossel oder sowas im im DSL gibt's ja auch keine vergleichbaren Angebote. Also ich würde da nicht argumentieren, dass das jetzt im im Interesse der Anbieter ist und deswegen sehe ich halt auch nicht, warum jetzt ARD und ZD.
Alle da mitmachen.
Warum sollte die ARD und ZDF damit machen? Machen sie? Wir sagen ja, ja, ist ja keine Diskriminierung, betrifft ja alle, ja äh scheiß drauf, ja. Also ihr ermöglicht äh der Telekom hier ein Businessmodell, was so einfach gar nicht existieren sollte.
Gut. So vielleicht mal zur technischen äh Beschreibung, so wie wir das verstanden haben und ganz ehrlich, es ist irgendwie eine komplexe Materie, wenn ihr nur noch andere Erkenntnisse habt, bitte äh in Kommentaren nachreichen. Kommen wir zu der eigentlichen Frage, nämlich.
Ist dieses Angebot, so wie die Telekom sich das jetzt ausgedacht hat, steht das äh im Einklang mit den neuen Netzneutralitätsrichtlinien. Da gibt's einen schönen, langen Text von äh,
geschätzten Kollegen. Thomas Loninger, der ja hier auch äh vor kurzem mal wieder äh ausführlich zu Gast kam und ja auch äh ähm
zu Gast war und äh häufiger schon zur Sprache kam, gerade wenn's um Netzneutralität geht. Bürger werden sich erinnern, dass er ja ganz maßgeblich,
daran beteiligt war diese neuen Netzneutralitätsrichtlinien auf europäischer Ebene so durchzufechten, wie es am Ende gekommen ist. Und da saß ja lange, lange Zeit sehr schlecht aus und dann äh am Thomas und dann war alles gut,
Weitgehend zumindest, gibt halt nur ein paar Ausnahmen und genau auf diesen Ausnahmen,
Versucht sich jetzt die Telekom auszuruhen und ähm da geht es primär dadrum, dass es heißt na ja.
Es wird den Telekom den Telekommunikationsunternehmen schon zugestanden.
Optimierungen vorzunehmen, die technisch erforderlich sind, um den Betrieb als solches aufrechtzuerhalten.
Lustigerweise nennt ja die Telekom ihre Drossel auch nicht Drossels, sondern sie nennt sie halt,
Optimierung, ja? Man optimiert auf DVD-Qualität, ja? Das ist ungefähr so, als ob man äh irgendjemand den den Hals abschnürt und sagt, ja, ich ich optimiere jetzt mal deinen, dein, deinen Luftzugang.
Auf Gartenschlauchqualität.
Äh ja genau und ähm oder weniger, weil das äh mehr mehr Luft wäre eher nicht da.
Ja und wir müssen ja die Luft auch äh gleichmäßig verteilen. Ähm.
Diese Optimierung ist aber offenbar anders gemeint und die darf halt nicht auf bestimmten kommerziellen.
Überlegungen fußen. Das scheint aber hier der Fall zu sein, weil es ja nicht der einzige Tarif ist, den es dort gibt, sondern es ist halt dieser Stream-On-Tarif und es gibt ja auch noch andere. Also äh gibt es hier schon eine entsprechende äh kommerzielle.
Ähm Motivation und das ist schon mal,
problematisch, dass diese Argumentation an dieser Stelle überhaupt ähm gewählt wird, weil damit ja dann auch dieses Best-Efford Prinzip ausgehebelt wird. Das Best-Afford-Prinzip.
Heißt halt Gänse generell mit ja Schaufel den Scheiß,
so gut wie es irgendwie geht durch und solange Platz ist, ist super und wenn äh alles halt sich staut, na ja, dann äh ist immer noch der Zeitpunkt gekommen, um über ausgleichende optimierende Maßnahmen nachzudenken,
aber man kann halt nicht von vornherein ein Tarif so gestalten, dass er eben sagt, ja wir schicken hier mal generell alles.
Langsamer, damit die Gesamtlast in unserem Netz sinkt, weil das ist im Prinzip das, was hinter diesem Tarif steht. Das heißt, man bietet jetzt einen billigen Tarif an, sagt,
Video unlimited, weil äh wir rechnen euch den anderen Kram nicht an, aber wir äh drosseln halt die Qualität
damit äh wir insgesamt nur noch auf fünfundzwanzig Prozent des gesamten Datenvolumens kommen und das äh da Video nun mal ein Großteil des Datentraffics heutzutage ausmacht,
klappt dann sozusagen unser,
Unsere Gesamtkalkulation. Ähm das kann man also hier auf jeden Fall schon mal unterstellen, dass an dieser Stelle eine kommerzielle Motivation am Start ist und dass es allein damit schon mal gegen die Prinzipien der Netzneutralität, so wie sie derzeit gilt,
verstößt,
Das zweite Problem ist, dass auch die Art und Weise, wie sie eben diese Tarifunterscheidung machen wollen, also die Identifikation der Teilnehmenden äh Partner.
Äh basiert ja, wie wir gesagt haben, teilweise auf IP-Adressen, dass wir, sagen wir mal, an sich vielleicht noch argumentierbar, aber insbesondere die
Geschichte mit dieser Inspektion mit, wir schauen uns mal die Zertifikate an,
Das ist halt das Betrachten von Daten, die oberhalb der eigentlichen Transportebene äh des Netzes liegen und das ist in den Berichtrichtlinien auch,
untersagt. Ähm,
Ja und ein dritter Punkt, den wir so noch gar nicht angesprochen haben ist, das Ganze ist natürlich ein Angebot in Deutschland für deutsche Kunden,
Diese ganze Information steht auf deutschen Webseiten in deutsch gehaltenen Excel-Schied, wo man sich mal was eintragen soll und die Kenntnis davon, dass es einen solchen Tarif gibt, der unter Umständen sehr viele äh Leute in Deutschland betrifft.
Der wird sich vielleicht ein bisschen rumsprechen und der wird bei den großen Anbietern ein Thema sein und äh am Montag früh als erstes auf dem Besprechungstisch liegen.
Aber es gibt natürlich noch zahlreiche andere Anbieter, die ganz interessant sind auf diesem Planeten, Round To Reald, wo was weiß ich, irgendwelche Italiener, Australier, Argentinier,
eben auch Sachen produzieren, die für einen relevant sind, weil muss ja nicht unbedingt immer alles aus Deutschland kommen, die darf man halt keine Kenntnis haben, die diese ganzen rechtlichen Unterscheidungen nicht äh äh kennen
die aber dann vielleicht auch nicht bereit sind, jetzt eine AGB zu unterzeichnen mit irgendwie fünfzigtausend Euro Vertragsscharf, äh wenn man irgendwie seine Pots falsch konfiguriert
mit der Telekom, mit einem Provider von
tausenden Providern auf diesem ganzen Planeten, äh was dann letzten Endes natürlich diesen Effekt hat, dass die halt aus dem vor sind, weil äh die werden einfach mal,
per se gedrosselt und ähm,
tragen in gewisser Hinsicht halt auch noch dazu bei, die Situation für die User noch schlimmer zu machen, weil ja dann noch das Datenvolumen noch zusätzlich angerechnet wird. Also,
mein Qualitäts, mein Testurteil, nicht so geil. Nicht so geil. Sechs. Sechs. Hm. Kaufen wir nicht. Nee.
Die Stiftung Prittlerfest hat entschieden äh Preisleistungsfeind. Das ist bei dir nie gut. Obwohl doch du. Also du würdest sagen links oben auf der Prittlerfala.
Ich bin das überhaupt gar nicht ins Angebot aufnehmen.
Also hier wird zumindest nicht aktiv Videoströme noch umgerechnet, das wäre auch der totale Wahnsinn. Ähm aber so wie das hier alles läuft, ist das nicht gut und wir pragern das an.
Es ist halt eine, es ist mal wieder so eine ein Nüdchenspielertrick.
Ja, baut einfach euer Scheiß Netz aus, sorgt dafür, dass die Leute das, was sie haben wollen, nämlich HD in entsprechenden Mengen, dass das einfach ankorm, nimmt den Preis, den das kostet fertig,
Und nicht hier so ein alberner Klimbim mit hinten rum und tralala. Genau deswegen haben wir diese Netzneutralitätsprinzipien jetzt eingeführt, damit ihr euch einfach mal am Markt.
Gilt übrigens auch, liebe Telekom, gilt auch für alle anderen. Ist nicht so, dass ihr in irgendeiner Form benachteiligt seid, sondern alle,
müssen auf dieser Basis an diesem Markt teilnehmen und da müsst ihr nicht solche blöden Nummern abziehen, wenn die anderen billiger anbieten können, dann liegt es vielleicht daran, dass sie einfach ihren Prozess und ihre äh Technik und ihr Unternehmen besser im Griff haben.
Oh Mann.
Echt. Geht weg.
Es ist aber wirklich spannend, dass man sich immer, also wie wie diese, was verträgt sie sich einfallen lassen, ne? Äh wie das für mich umsonst so, voll geil jetzt die Fahne. Und in Wirklichkeit drosseln sie dir dich irgendwie zurück in die Neunziger.
Dream on, Stream on.
Schön. So, dann kommen wir mal ähm zu einem Thema, das habe ich,
War ich letzte Woche irgendwie habe ich das behandelt beim ähm Thema Bundestagsnetz. Also seit,
September spätestens seit September zwanzig.
Sechzehn sind die sind viele Abgeordnete Bundestagsabgeordneten in heller Aufruhr.
Und haben Angst, dass sie jetzt gehackt werden, ne? Und der und der Wahlkampf manipuliert wird durch,
durch Hacking. Sie haben das ja gesehen, was mit dem was mit dem Democratic National Council passiert ist. Sie haben gesehen, was mit dem John Podesta passiert ist und sie haben natürlich keine Lust ähm,
Auf diese Weise eine Bundestagswahl zu verlieren. Deswegen die Parteien sind
Und ich denke natürlich zu Recht in in heller Offrohr und sorgen sich um ihre IT-Sicherheit. Jetzt hat so ein ähm Bundestagsabgeordnete per so die haben dann irgendwie erstmal,
natürlich im Bundestagsnetz irgendwelche Rechner stehen, mit denen sie da rumhantieren, dann haben die noch ein Handy und ein iPad, das sind in der Regel Privatgeräte. Ähm dann haben die vielleicht noch eine kleine Infrastruktur in ihren Wahlkreisbüros, dann haben die zu Hause was stehen. Ähm,
Die haben schon sagen wir mal eine nennenswerte Angriffsoberfläche, aber wie das Menschen in der
so tun, wenn sie sich um IT-Sicherheit sorgen, die gucken natürlich da, wo es am einfachsten ist, ne? Also für sie Verteidigung zu betreiben und nicht da, wo es am einfachsten ist, für einen Angreifer anzugreifen
Ähm.
Jedenfalls wurde im Rahmen dessen eine Sicherheits ähm ein Sicherheitsout des Netzes des Deutschen Bundestages,
vorgenommen und zwar am Anfang des Jahres zweitausendsiebzehn. Von einem ähm Beratungsunternehmen in diesem Bereich,
dass eher für den organisatorischen Teil der IT-Sicherheit,
mir bekannt ist als für den den offensiven Teil, also ne man kann sich ja, man kann ja einmal sagen so es gibt einfach best Practices und wir gucken, ob die umgesetzt sind.
Und es gibt definierte Sicherheitsniveaus und wir gucken, ob die erreicht sind oder ob es gibt Maßnahmen, definierte Maßnahmenkataloge und wir gucken, ob die erfüllt sind. Und es gibt dann irgendwie so, sage ich mal, der Teil, der in dieses äh in dieser Branche natürlich einfach sehr viel mehr Spaß macht
dass es den ganzen Aktenordner auf Seite zu schieben
einfach mal reinzuprügeln und zu gucken, wie man am Ende reingekommen ist. Das ist das, was sehr viel mehr Spaß macht, was ich auch an dieser Tätigkeit natürlich liebe, ähm ist aber natürlich auch andererseits das, wofür man am am wenigsten bezahlt wird, ne. Man wird ja dafür bezahlt,
Sicherheitslücken zu finden und zu entfernen und das ist in der Regel sehr viel einfacher, wenn man einfach nur mal guckt, gibt uns mal die Dokumentation, da finde ich schon genug Fehler.
War das nicht schön, als man so als Zweijähriger einfach auf alles draufhauen konnte?
Ja, ich bin nur als, als Zweijähriger nicht an den Punkt gekommen, nachher zu sagen, siehste, deswegen ist das kaputt. Und so ist das jetzt heile.
Hier ist meine Rechnung.
So, jetzt,
Jetzt lag dieser, dieser Bericht lag also aus im deutschen Bundestag, in so einem stillen Kämmerlein, wo man irgendwie wohl nur ausgewählte Leute rein durften und so weiter. Und jetzt sind ähm.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo dieser Raum war.
Jetzt sind also Teile davon, äh, Teile dieses des Inhaltes geliegt, sind also hundert Seiten und ich hatte dann ähm im Rahmen der Berichterstattung letzte Woche auch Gelegenheit, mir das anzuschauen.
Und ähm da sind dann so ein paar Sachen drin, kritisiert die ich auf den ersten Blick,
Also fragwürdig finde, ne? Also wenn du so jemanden bestellst, so ein so ein Ordnungssecurity-Ordnungs,
Menschen, ne, so ein Auditor. Der findet immer irgendwas, ne? Der kommt mit einem so dermaßen riesigen Katalog, dass der immer irgendetwas findet, wo du gegen die best Practices verstößt. So. Ähm.
Die Frage ist dann, ähm dass diese Bemängelungen abzugleichen mit dem mit dem Angriffsniveau oder Angriffsdruck und dem wahrscheinlichen Szenarien, den man selber ausgesetzt ist.
Und ähm nach meiner nach meinem Dafürhalten waren ein paar,
von den Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die da empfohlen wurden, eher dem.
Paranoidenbereich zuzuordnen, die am Ende,
ein nicht besonnen, also ein nicht nennenswerten Zuwachs an Sicherheit gegen die zu erwartenden Szenarien bieten.
Gleichzeitig aber irgendwie viel Kosten und viel Ärger machen, ne? Sowas so was möchte man eigentlich nicht haben.
Ähm andererseits waren da einige Mängel dabei, die ich äh die ich also die ich überhaupt nicht verstehe. Weil ich gehe jetzt mal so Auszüge davon, ähm der der Reihe nach durch. Also als erstes wurde irgendwie dann
Okay, ja, also ein das größte Problem, das wird auch gerade in den in den Nachrichten hoch und runter gerollt, äh wäre, dass die,
Bundestagsabgeordneten, eigene Geräte benutzen.
Dürfen im Bundestagsnetz. Nennt sich die Bringer on Device, das heißt äh man man stattet nicht mehr das gesamte Unternehmen mit mit Firmengeräten aus,
sondern die Leute dürfen auch ihre Privatgeräte nutzen, wie es eben auch die ähm die Politiker in den Bundestagen die ganze Zeit mit ihren iPads und so weiter tun. Das hatten wir ja hier schon behandelt,
Natürlich sagt dann die IT. Ja, das ist aber nicht gut, weil.
Diese eigenen Geräte, die ihr da habt, die entziehen sich ja unseren hohen Sicherheitsstandards. Das heißt, da ist, da können wir euch nicht eine Passwortpolicy drauf machen. Da haben wir keine Kontrolle, was ihr darauf installiert. Das heißt, den trauen wir nicht. Vor denen haben wir Angst.
Und äh ich glaube so der Übliche der übliche,
'ne übliche Maßnahme ist zu sagen, okay, man hat dann eben ein separates Netzwerksegment, wo diese privaten Geräte rein dürfen und das hält man aber sich dann von seinem eigenen wichtigen Kram fern und dann lebt man damit, dass die Leute das eben ohnehin,
tun und man es nicht verhindern kann. Das heißt, man schützt sich so ein bisschen gegen diese einen Geräte.
Und man schützt auch die Geräte auch besser, weil man sie dann nicht in Mobilfunknetze zwingt, wo sie sonst irgendwie würden oder sich ihre eigenen WLANs aufbauen.
Genau, man kann dann wenigstens noch sagen, komm, dann komm, wenigstens in unser WLAN, da haben wir dann nochmal irgendwie eine Firewall und und 'ne Webeplication
irgendwie gegen gegen gegen irgendwelche Trojanerangriffe oder sowas, dann hast du wenigstens unseren Proxi nochmal davor, so kann man dann machen, ne? Ähm.
Das Ganze hat aber auch ein anderes Extrem, nämlich dass die, dass man so eine sichere,
Also sag mal, eine paranoidsichere IT-Infrastruktur ähm macht den Nutzern keinen Spaß mehr. Und dann werden die nicht nur ihre eigenen Geräte mitnehmen, sondern dann werden die versuchen, mit ihren eigenen Geräten ihre Arbeit zu erledigen,
und ähm es ist also relativ häufig der Fall, dass man, wenn man jetzt mit Bundestagsabgeordneten kommuniziert
vielleicht nicht unbedingt die Fraktions- oder Bundestags-E-Mail-Adresse
zur zum Einsatz kommt, sondern vielleicht mal so ein Jahr wo oder so eine so eine Jeanadresse, weil das mit der Privaten einfach unkomplizierter geht und die kann ich auch auf dem iPad lesen, da komme ich auch am Wochenende dran. Das heißt, du hast dann
die Leute flüchten aus deinem sicheren Netz, aus der in die in das Private.
Ähm und und arbeiten dann dort und entziehen sich dann vollständig der Kund.
Das Private ist politisch.
Entzieht sich dann da vollständig deiner Kontrolle, ne? Das ist dann so der der negative Effekt von zu hoher IT-Sicherheit. Und der Bundestag scheint beide Probleme zu haben. Ähm.
Andererseits aber prinzipiell kannst du das kann man das nur,
schwer einfach sich in so einem Bericht jetzt hinstellen, sagen, das ist ein Problem. Weil wenn man ein Problem ankreidet, dann sollte man ja auch eine Lösung dafür benennen. Ähm das andere, was sie groß
kritisieren und als als Problempunkt und da da läuft's mir ja immer kalt den Rücken runter. Ist ja ähm,
da sind die Leute dürfen USB benutzen, ne. Das ist jetzt auch also spätestens seit Bad USB ähm dem
Dem Angriff über USB den ähm Jakob Lell und Carsten Nohl, meine ehemaligen Arbeitskollegen demonstriert haben ähm
Das große Thema, ne, dass man die USB-Ports überall zukleben soll
Und da würde ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, na ja, also in der OK kann man sagen, ne? Aber das im Bundestag sind viele tausend Leute, die da an vielen tausend Geräten arbeiten, denen die USB-Sticks zu verbieten. Das wird einfach nur dazu führen, dass sie den Miss bei Dropbox hochladen oder
oder bei mega Share oder so was, ne? Also das ist keine das ist keine Lösung eines Problemes. Die wollen USB
Geräte benutzen, die müssen die in ihrem Alltag benutzen, das ja, das ist ein Problem, aber denen wirst du nicht beikommen. Insofern fand ich das ein bisschen unsinnig.
Ähm oder fand ich das dem Schutzniveau,
Oder äh war mir das ein zu paranoides Schutzniveau, wenn du ohnehin schon darunter leidest, dass die Leute die Bundestags IT nämlich gar nicht nutzen.
Ähm aber dann kommen wir mal zu den zu den wirklich spannenden Sachen, was dann der Stand ist, dass sie im Prinzip kein Application Whitelisting benutzen. Ähm oder oder Codesining oder sonst was. Das heißt, auf all diesen Geräten, die da stehen,
Auf diesen Bundestagsrechnern lässt sich jedes beliebige ähm Executible ausführen.
Und der Computer beschwert sich nicht, ähm dass er da jetzt irgendetwas ausführt. Warum ist das,
so dramatisch. Nun, zweitausendfünfzehn war es, dass sie ihren ersten Trojaner Angriff hatten,
der erfolgreich war, wo mehrere Gigabyte-Daten aus dem Bundestagsnetz rausgepult wurden
Und wir bis heute wissen wir nicht, welche Daten das waren, wo die hin sind, ähm wer sie hat, von wem dieser Angriff ausging. Es gibt Spekulationen, dass das irgendwie,
von einer russischen Hackergruppe kam, aber es gibt keine Aufklärung darüber, was da rausgeholt wurde. So, wenn du, wenn dein, wenn du schon mal dieses Problem hattest,
Spätestens dann solltest du aber relativ klar dafür sorgen, dass deine Computer, die da stehen, nicht
beliebigen Mist ausführen, wie es nämlich bei einem Trojaner der Fall ist. Natürlich kann der Trojaner über ein Word Marko kommen
natürlich kann der IBA eine Ivane, eine Mevetising-Kampagne kommen, der kann auch von einem USB-Stick kommen, weshalb ja die,
Kollegen da meinen, sie müssen jetzt irgendwie die ganzen USB-Pots abkleben oder sowas, ja? Oder USB vollständig in Bayers, die aktivieren oder was auch immer, die sich dann da vorstellen, was ja eben auch nicht so einfach ist, weil die Tastatur da ja auch noch dran steckt
Ähm natürlich kann man das alles machen, aber am Ende wird dieser Trojaner.
Persistenz auf dem Betriebssystem erlangen wollen und das tut er, indem er ein Executible,
ist, was entweder regelmäßig äh neu ausgeführt wird oder beim Start irgendwie gestartet wird. Und wenn ich meinem Computer beibringe, dass er nur Software ausführt,
die von mir vorher ähm erlaubt wurde,
und dann eine lange Liste hat, ähm entweder eine lange Liste an Prüfsummen für welche Sachen er ausführen darf oder man sagt die Software, die du ausführen darfst, wird mit einem Zertifikat nochmal signiert. Dann bin ich dieses Problem.
Größtenteils los. Natürlich kann jede einzelne Sicherheitsmaßnahme wieder umgangen werden und es gibt immer mal wieder einen Schwachsteller.
Aber in einem dann doch ähm was die Informationssicherheit angeht, höchstkritischen Bereich,
wo man schon mal genau dieses Szenario hatte, nämlich eine Schadsoftware Infektion auf den Rechnern.
Ähm nicht damit äh zu arbeiten, halte ich für fahrlässig,
Wir haben das dann auch ähm geprüft, der Thorsten Schröder hatte ähm hat dann irgendwie mal schnell ausm Arm geschüttelt, einfach mal beliebige Beine riesig. Es ging uns einfach darum, Programme zu haben, die.
Ging einfach ein Fenster auf, ne? Also ein wir brauchten einfach ein unbekanntes Programm
dass noch niemand auf dieser Welt kennt, ja? Und diese, das wurde dann mal auf zum Bundestagsrechner ausgeführt und es ging problemlos. Mit anderen Worten hätten wir einen klugen Trojaner gebaut, dann wäre das ähm auch der Fall gewesen.
Und ähm da wäre natürlich unschön gewesen. Ähm das heißt, seit zweitausendfünfzehn nicht die
nicht dieses relevante Maßnahme gezogen, da mal ähm dass das promiskultive Ausführungsverhalten der Computer äh in den Griff zu kriegen, ja?
Die Paarungswilligkeit der Bundestagsdigitalinfrastruktur.
Die Exekutionswilligkeit da, ja. Und dann haben sie noch irgendwie eine unsaubere Netzwerkseparierung bemängelt. Das war, da habe ich aber zu wenig Details zugesehen, um das zu beurteilen.
Tja, also das, das macht jetzt gerade die Runde. Also, dass da nicht mit, dass da nicht irgendwie mit Wildlisting gearbeitet wird, halte ich für für insbesondere in Anbetracht des schon geschehenen, für sehr fragwürdig.
Und ähm bin überrascht. Gleichzeitig werde ich
Die ganze Zeit gefragt, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass da jemand einbricht und ich meine Antwort ist eigentlich immer ein gewisses, dass da jetzt noch jemand einwill, der ist relativ unwahrscheinlich. Die haben das nämlich im Zweifelsfall vor einem halben oder einem dreiviertel Jahr getan und ähm ich weiß nicht
Man kann nur hoffen.
Genauso zytisch sage ich natürlich dann auch, wenn mich jemand fragt, wie können wir uns schützen? Ist halt löschen so, ne? Also lösch den Scheiß so. Löscht euer löscht äh eure alten E-Mails, löscht was es nur geht, löscht alle,
Spuren eurer ganzen korrupten Tätigkeiten und geheimen Absprachen, die ihr mit irgendjemanden hattet und eure Hintergrundtreffen denn ähm
es ist schon relativ wahrscheinlich, dass das jemand daraus pult. Ich habe da jetzt auch nicht die ähm die.
Also ich hätte eine Patentlösung,
mir einfallen lassen können, wenn ich mehrere Monate mich auch mit diesem Netzwerk auseinandergesetzt hätte. Ich hätte halt nur erwartet, dass sowas eben zweitausendfünfzehn geschieht und nicht irgendwie im Frühjahr zwanzig siebzehn
irgendwann mal jemand so ein, so einen Bericht der abliefert und sagt, das müsstet ihr tun. Ja, also so langsam
dürfen gerade in der IT-Sicherheit gerade in so einem dann doch hochkritischen Bereich die Mühlen nicht mal ein gleichzeitig auch hier für die die Bundestagsabgeordneten, den muss man natürlich auch sagen,
könnt ihr jetzt groß quengeln, dass eure IT nicht gut wäre, aber im Zweifelsfall ist das, was ihr in euren Wahlkreisbüros unterhaltet und äh und in euren Taschen habt und wie ihr euch an dieser Bundestags-IT über die nämlich sonst immer gemeckert wird, weil sie einem im Weg ist, äh wenn ihr euch der nicht äh unter eine werfen wollt, also das das ähm
Die Münze hat zwei Seiten und es ist äh beunruhigend.
Ja, gar nicht so einfach, ne? Man merkt auch wieder, wie so das Wissen eigentlich um, um um all diese ganzen Zusammenhänge einfach sich äh langsam nur aufbaut.
Ja und das ist natürlich tragisch, das ist dann eben so, aber also.
Die werden im Zweifelsfall, wer wird so ein Bundestagsabgeordneter oder so eine Fraktion nicht gehackt, weil
eine ein russischer Hacker sich mit einem infizierten USB-Stick eine Bundestagsführung geben lässt und den USB-Stick in den Rechner eines Bundestagsabgeordneten steckt, wenn der gerade nicht da ist
ja? Das könnte sein, dass das auch das Angriffsszenario ist, dass wahrscheinlichere und sehr viel elegantere ist halt einfach so ein hier in der mal dein Passwort,
hier ist die Bundestags-IT, wir haben jetzt eine neue Firewall, äh klick mal hier, dass es über so etwas funktioniert. Ja, das halte ich für das,
für das wahrscheinlichere Szenario und ich habe das hier schon oft genug ausgeführt, dass eben Hacker da draußen in der,
in der freien Wirtschaft oder in der freien Wildbahn, wie auch immer man das nennen möchte. Ähm nicht darauf aus sind, besonders große Kunststücke zu verführen,
die möchten eher relativ einfach zum Ziel kommen.
Natürlich nicht entdeckt werden, aber wenn sie entdeckt werden, soll's eben auch nicht nach Staat aussehen, sondern soll immer noch,
nach einem problemlos, nach einem äh Skript Kiddie aussehen können und genau das ist ja auch beim Bundestag ähm,
passiert, als sie das erste Mal,
gehackt wurden mit einem Trojaner, Standardtrojaner Toolkit von der Stange. Da werden keine neuen Künste zum Einsatz gebracht, weil wenn es nicht unbedingt notwendig ist.
Ja, also passt auf Bundestag. Die Daten sind eh schon weg.
Auf jeden Fall.
So, dann gibt's äh ich wollte das Thema Werbenetzwerke nochmal so ein bisschen aufgreifen und zwar von der wirtschaftlich gesellschaftlichen Perspektive. Ich bin nämlich über zwei ganz interessante äh,
Badartikel da gestoßen. Einmal von einer Webseite namens Ground ab oder so, die glaube ich hauptsächlich in Südafrika operiert.
Ähm die begründen, die sagt, wir machen jetzt nichts mehr mit Google Ads. Und die sagen, dass das Problem ist, dass alle Macht in diesem Verhältnis äh der Online-Werbung bei Google liegt. Ähm
sagen der das einzelne Newsoutlet ähm steht also in Konkurrenz.
Um Werbeanzeigen mit den anderen News Outlets,
die im gleichen Markt stehen. Also du bist jetzt Groundup und dein Konkurrent heißt Metaebene, du bist quasi du musst quasi in Konkurrenz treten zu Meterebene und damit überhaupt bei dir Werbung ähm angezeigt wird. Das übernimmt ja.
Für dich Google, Google sitzt ja einfach an beiden
Also das das Google Werbenetzwerk wird bei beiden Seiten eingebunden und trifft da die ähm die Entscheidungen, wer wann welche Werbung bekommt. Deswegen ist sie dann auch gerne mal ähm,
sage ich mal, dem Inhalt der Seite nicht zu zu äh zu ordnen,
sondern eher dem Betrachter und dem, was das Ferbelnetzwerk über die Person weiß. Jetzt beklagen die sich aber, ja, am Ende, weil die Bike alle Macht bei Google ist und wir für keine Handlung irgendwie eine Alternative haben,
äh wären wir natürlich auch sehr, sehr wenig bezahlt. So Werbung, Internetwerbung wirft eben sehr, sehr wenig abbeklagen die sich hier.
Ähm und sie sagen, sie hatten zum Beispiel über dreihundertzwanzigtausend äh Visits. Ähm von.
Annähernd einer Viertelmillion Nutzer und haben damit zweitausend ähm.
Zweitausendsiebenhundertvierundfünfzig, jetzt muss ich gerade nochmal ganz kurz überlegen, wie die, wie die Währung denn heißt Rand, ne? Zweitausendvierhundert Rand bekommen.
Und ähm sagen so über's übers Jahr bekommen sie vielleicht dann mal äh zwanzigtausend Rand und das sind eben eintausenddreihundertsiebenundachtzig Euro,
die die im Jahr mit dieser Werbung machen und sagen, das ist einfach nicht mehr wert, ihren Inhalt,
mit äh teilweise irgendwelchen Schrottads von Google zu ähm zu füllen. Mit irgendwelchen Werdeschnellreich, Werbungen von wo irgendwelche Leute drin sind
die oder wo die Bilder von Prominenten benutzt werden, die dem nie zugestimmt haben und wo quasi die Werbung selber.
Schlimmer, also schlimmer Content ist, ne? Also Verarschung der Nutzer und äh Verletzung der Urheberrechte oder oder Verwertungsrechte an diesen Bildern, von diesen Prominenten oder so und sagen, also diesen Mist
äh wollen, lassen wir uns von euch nicht weiter einblenden, denn sie haben eine E-Mail bekommen von Google, die sich beschwert haben, dass in einem Bild auf ihrer Webseite, ja, wo dieses dieses News Magazin drüber berichtet hat
Nacktheit zu sehen sei. Und das ist irgendwie ein Bild von irgendeiner Museums.
Installation, da liegen irgendwie zwei Leute mit dem freien Oberkörper auf dem Boden. Ne, weil sie irgendeine Kunstgeschichte.
Oder war's vielleicht auch politischer Prozess? Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau.
Kann auch ein politisches war irgendwie so, also sah, sah aus wie sah aus wie Kunst, kann aber auch ein politischer Protest gewesen.
Ist das politischer Protest oder kann das weg.
Ähm.
Und.
Äh das hat Google offenbar nicht gefallen, dann haben die den automatische Mail geschrieben, haben gesagt, hier ähm ähm Nudity ist gegen unsere Trumps of Services und äh jetzt muss das äh jetzt geht das nicht.
So, da haben die, da hat der dann gesagt, okay, jetzt reicht's, ne, wenn ihr uns irgendwie hier allen möglichen Scheiß äh auf die Seite pappt, der uns unseriös aussehen lässt, weil es irgendwie
Abzug ist und gleichzeitig uns irgendwie vorwirft über Kunst oder oder Kultur oder sowas Bericht zu erstatten. Dann sind wir damit nicht mehr einverstanden, dann beenden wir das jetzt. Ein sehr ähnliches Problem.
Hat die Tagesschutzzeitung TAZ ähm die ähm seit Anfang Januar,
den Google Ad Server bei sich zum Einsatz hat und eine sehr irritierende E-Mail bekommen hat, wie Martin Kaul, der ein Tatzredakteur im
im im Hausblock irgendwie beschreibt, denn es wurde gesagt, dass da eine bestimmte URL den Richtlinien der Firma widersprechen würde?
Und ähm ihr Adpartner wieder, ich meine, das sind ja alles immer hundertachtzig Intermediaries, ihr der Edpartner, der Tarz-Hatter, also irgendwie eine E-Mail bekommen, wo du anscheinend betroffene Webseite Touch DE. Ähm,
Es geht, nehmen sie umgehend Änderungen an ihrer Webseite vor, sodass sie wieder den Etzensprogrammrichtlinien entspricht.
In der offenbar maschinell erstellten E-Mail heißt es weiterhin im Falle von weiteren Verstößen ist es möglich, dass wir die Anzeigenschaltung auf der oben genannten Webseite deaktivieren. Nehmen Sie sich daher umgehend Zeit dafür, ihren Content zu überprüfen und sicherzustellen, dass er unseren Richtlinien entspricht.
Wenn sie eine Benachrichtigung erhalten haben, weil der Content auf einer Seite gegen die Richtlinien verstößt, entfernen sie entweder den betroffenen Content von ihrer Webseite,
oder entfern sie Anzeigen aus den Seiten mit diesem Content. Also man könnte auch sagen okay auf dieser Seite wird dann eben Etzens nicht mehr angezeigt.
Spannend ist welche Seite bemängelt Google den dort,
ja, klickt man mal auf die Seite, sieht man YouTube-Musik als MP3 runterladen. Das Recht auf Privatkopie. Und es wird berichtet über einen Rechtsstreit, den Google.
Mit einer Webseite hat, die ähm es ermöglicht, aus YouTube Videos MP3, Musik zu extrahieren.
Also der Rechtsstreit ist im Wesentlichen so ein Season The Sistletal, den sie da mal hingeschickt haben, so nach dem Motto hier äh schaltet euch mal ab, sonst.
Ja, also das das ich meine, man kann verstehen, was der, was der das Konzept dieser,
Diese Seite ist, ne, irgendjemand hat ein Musikvideo veröffentlicht und du willst das MP3 auf deinem ähm auf deinem MP3 Player haben oder oder auf deiner auf deinem.
Offline Kopie haben davon.
Eine offline Offline-Möglichkeit, ne, weil da weil damit du nicht dein Datenvolumen runterfährst mit dem ganzen mit dem Video-Streaming.
Ja, ist so, ja, mal auch schon mal passiert sein.
Ja, ist natürlich schon interessant ähm dass Google ausgerechnet diesen Inhalt dann da sagt so äh der entspricht nicht unseren äh unseren Richtlinien. Ähm.
Geil. Also da merkt man wirklich, dass diese Vermischung von Werbetätigkeit und dem Durchsetzen privater äh Interessen einfach einen starken Konflikt steh.
Jetzt muss man, jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, dass ähm dass deswegen habe ich die Sätze extra nochmal unterstrichen. Martin Kaul schreibt, eventuell denkt Google ja, dass die Seite, auf die der Taztext verlinkt, rechtswidrig ist,
obwohl sie wollen sie das noch gar nicht ist, der Rechtsstreit läuft ja weiter. Oder es ließe sich denken, möglicherweise nutzt Google seine Marktmacht, um eine ungeliebten Nebenbooder,
aus dem Markt zu drängen, nicht weil dessen Angebot rechtswidrig ist, sondern weil Google selbst es als solches definiert.
Ähm ja, wichtiger Punkt. Natürlich Google äußert sich da nicht zu. Ähm es ist es steht auch, denke ich, der ähm.
Bei beiden Fällen der Verdacht im Raum, dass da irgendein.
Mal noch fein kalibriert werden muss und eben zu viel Hautfarbe in dem einen Bild entdeckt hat
'ne Liste potentiell edegaler Links hat, äh, wo man nicht hin verweisen soll und da jetzt aus Versehen dieses dieser MP drei Extraktionsservice,
mit aufgefallen ist, aber es ist trotzdem sehr unschön, denn für für die Webseiten sind das natürlich trotzdem massive.
Einnahmen einbußen, mit denen Google da droht. Und ähm das ist nicht schön ähm wenn wenn du in einem Markt ein derartiges, riesiges Gefälle hast, weil es gibt eben eigentlich keinen sinnvollen
Konkurrenten zu diesem Google Adnitz mehr, ja? Und das heißt, sie können natürlich sagen, du machst darüber Bericht, dass du bitte nicht oder entfernst da die Werbung,
Wenn das nochmal vorkommt, dann müssen wir auch nicht mit dir zusammenarbeiten. Und das ist schon echt, das ist,
beunruhigend das Werbe-Netzwerke auch an dieser Stelle jetzt
ähm eine eine so so krude Rolle in unserer Gesellschaft spielen. Also diese gesamte Entwicklung zu zu diesen zentralisierten Werbenetzwerken, zu allen Problemen, die wir äh da noch mit haben.
Ist ähm sehr, sehr unglücklich. Und das äh ist eines der Probleme, was wir in Zukunft mal lösen müssen.
Da wird eh spannend zu sehen, inwiefern dieses Werbemodell ähm so eine Rolle ähm beibehalten wird, wie es jetzt in den letzten Jahren im Netz gehabt hat. Mal,
Netz ist in seiner kurzen Lebenszeit schon durch die eine oder andere Phase gegangen
Jetzt haben wir halt grade so diese Phase des alles ist Werbung und Werbung finanziert alles und alles muss sich dem Diktat der Werbung
unter äh unterwerfen. Wir hatten das ja auch schon mit so Klickstrecken und und und tausend
Einzelteile zerschnittene Artikel, die einfach nur dazu da sind, dass halt da irgendwie Klicks hochgehen und dadurch dann eben
mehr Werbeeinblendungen erzeugt werden und dann da so Geldmaschinen halt quasi wieder angeworfen werden, einen anderen Grund erzahlt einfach nicht, weil der User steht dann halt ähm
immer hinten an und das halt äh etwas, wo man eben sagen kann,
Werbung ist sicherlich nicht grundlegend eine schlechte Sache,
Ja, also ich würde ja jetzt auch nicht sagen wollen. Ähm, dass Werbung per se unanständig ist.
Wenn ich eine Dienstleistung habe und ich.
Möchte darauf hinweisen, warum soll ich nicht die Aufmerksamkeitsmöglichkeiten, die sich an bestimmten Outlets für was auch immer äh ergeben nutzen,
Hat's mit Zeitungen, hat das lange Zeit äh viele hundert Jahre äh funktioniert und jetzt haben wir einfach diese Universaldisruption durch das Internet.
Wo sich die Dinge dann wieder neu äh einpendeln müssen und derzeit schlagen halt die Pendel extrem äh auseinander, ne? Wir haben den Sicherheitsaspekt,
schon mehrfach hier angesprochen, dass äh die das Potenzial der Verteilung von Malware, Ranson Ware und anderen äh unangenehmen Dingen über Werbeportale, so wie sie eben derzeit funktionieren. Ähm das Beispiel jetzt mit Südafrika gehabt, dass einfach
ja man sich hier mit diesen Netzwerken quasi auch äh in der Allianz äh begibt mit jemanden, der eigentlich so für einen nichts tut
Ja oder zumindest nicht unbedingt äh zwingend förderlich ist. Wenn man das aber selber in die Hand nimmt, äh die ganze Werbung, dann lohnt sie sich halt auch äh noch weniger,
Bis hin zu diesem private Interessen des der der Werbe äh Netzwerke.
Oder eben auch der Werbung selber, wie man das ja auch kennt,
mischt sich hier mit ein. Die anderen Modelle, die Spendenmodelle, die äh Service äh Bezahlmodelle.
Haben ja immerhin in manchen Teilen schon gezeigt, dass es auch geht,
Das Kräfteverhältnis in zehn Jahren aussehen wird in dieser Hinsicht weiß ich nicht. Ist äh wirklich offen. Mieterebene zum Beispiel ist ja Werbefrei.
Unter anderem auch.
Präsentiert von Kasper.
Der einzige Kasper bin ich und äh ja gut meinetwegen. Also wir sind.
Ich will auch ein Kasperle sein.
Ja, ich bin äh Kasperle und äh hier ist noch gleich der andere.
Ich finde Sepp.
Wie folgt es denn nun? Wurde ihnen präsentiert von Kasperle, Kasperle und Sempel. Ähm.
Ja, wird sich zeigen, äh wie nachhaltig das ist, aber äh ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob die Kräfteverhältnisse, so wie wir sie derzeit sehen, noch so lange aufrechterhalten werden können.
Ja, das muss sich, also das muss sich ändern. Diese Werbeindustrie hat ja sowieso eine ein ganz,
Skurrilen Wandel hinter sich, ne? Also überlegt mal, wir haben äh in in Printradio und Fernsehmedien
haben die in so einem, in so einem maximalen äh Dunkel äh operiert, ne? Da haben wir gesagt, schalten wir mal eine Anzeige da, gucken wir mal da und dann lassen wir irgendeinen Marktvorsprungsinstitut fragen. Äh ob die Leute die Marke kennen und ob die was positives damit assoziieren oder so, ne? Eine soll da so liest Werbung die hatten.
Überhaupt kein keine Idee davon auf ihre Werbung ankommt oder nicht keine messbaren.
Dem Kunden konnten sie es nicht belegen.
Konnten konnten, konnten kein messbaren Beleg. Ähm heute hast du diese Ed-Netzwerke, die das überall hinballern, die das für dich optimieren und zwar nicht
in die Medien, wo du sein willst, sondern zu den Kunden, die du erreichen möchtest. Das machen die quasi automatisch. Ähm du kannst als, du hast kompletten Überblick darüber, ist, du kriegst als,
derjenige dessen der die Fläche auf seiner Webseite vermietet. Unterschiedliches Geld, Abhängigkeit davon, ob die Leute gesehen haben, geklickt haben oder was gekauft haben
Also du kannst und als Werbetreibender kannst du all das halt optimal sehen. Du kannst auch zwei Anzeigen äh schalten und innerhalb von wenigen Minuten weißt du welche von beiden bei den Leuten besser ankommen, ne? Du hast wirklich live
Statistik äh über all das und du kannst eindeutig hundert Prozent erkennen, was dir die Kampagne gebracht hat oder nicht,
Kannst es direkt zu den Käufen, ähm, wenn es jetzt irgendwie so ein Online-Shop ist oder so was direkt zu den Käufen ähm
beziehen und sagen, okay, das hat so und so viel gebracht und kannst im Prinzip eine einfache Rechnung aufstellen, wie wenn ich diese Anzeige jetzt nochmal schalte für,
zweihundert Euro, dann meine Nummer ähm so und so viel Umsatz.
Und das auch an sich nichts, nichts, nichts Schlechtes, das möchte ich mit den äh Unternehmen mir auch gönnen. Jeder möchte sein Geld in äh ja optimal einsetzen und nicht
für Dinge verbrauchen, wo nur eine Werbeagentur dran versteht, nur die Implikation für die Privatsphäre und die Sicherheit sind halt nicht zu verleugnen.
Genau, die Implikationen für die Privatsphäre sind das große Problem, weil diese Ad-Netzwerke eben die Leute tracken. Und eigentlich ist gar nicht mehr darum geht, also niemand triff,
ich, ja, ja, keiner trifft mir die Entscheidung, wir möchten auf der und der Seite werben.
Es wird die Entscheidung getroffen. Wir möch
so und so werben bei der und der Zielgruppe. Natürlich bucht man dann sowas wie was weiß ich, Spiegel online, oben so ein Benner Ad, da klickt man nochmal, das bucht man nochmal separat, aber so allgemein, so eine so das das äh das neunzig Prozent des Endgeschäftes ist einfach
Kannst ja irgendwie einfach einfl.
Ja und dann stellen halt die tollen Brands fest, dass ihr Scheiß halt über Breitbandnews auch irgendwie in die Welt gepustet wird und dann halt einfach da diesen Schummer der Nazis äh direkt die Kohle äh
in Säcke reinschmiert. Also von daher ist glaube ich das die Nachfrage nach Blacklists äh doch deutlich größerer äh geworden. Ähm auch so ein Problem.
Ja, also ist kein kein schönes Phänomen, aber es ist halt auch man kann verstehen, warum es sich genauso entwickelt hat, wie es jetzt ist.
So das finde ich halt, das finde ich das Ärgerliche daran. Es ist ganz klar, dass die die Anreize und die Optimierung, die man an Online-Werbung vornehmen könnte, genau auf dieses Modell hinauslaufen,
dass du einen großen Anbieter hast und dann natürlich auch diese unschönen Effekte hast. Ich stelle das nur immer wieder äh immer wieder fest, dass diese unschönen Auswüchse äh von,
ja von Kapital von kapitalistischer äh Optimierung äh sehr häufig zu diesen unschönen zentralen Strukturen führen.
Und dann eben auch den Markt möchten die damit einhergehen.
So, haben wir noch was auf dem Zettel?
Ja, kurz, kurz jetzt, ne? Meister.
Äh
Also es gibt eine, eine Änderung im EU Grenzkodex, die jetzt irgendwie von der Bundespolizei äh auch äh umgesetzt wird und bekanntgegeben wurde. Bislang wurden an den EU-Außengrenzen lediglich die Daten von nicht EU-Bürgern
systematisch mit allen Sicherheitsdaten, Banken abgeglichen,
Und das auch nur bei der Einreise. Ja, also bis nicht EU-Bürger, dann werden deine Daten da erfasst und mit einer Sicherheitsdatenbank äh verglichen.
Wegen auch immer separate Schlangen.
Genau, deswegen ähm weil es in der anderen eben ein bisschen länger dauert.
Und eine andere Juristiksiktion auch dann zum Einsatz kam, kommt.
So, jetzt haben sie es geändert, das wird gelten, auch für die Ausreise aus der EU, also auch wenn du raus willst und sowieso für alle EU-Bürger auch.
Das heißt, alle, wer da egal was, wer durch so eine Passkontrolle geht, wird ähm,
Einem systematischen Abgleich der personenbezogenen Daten und des Reisedekumens mit dem mit dem Fahndungsbestand unterzogen.
Das heißt, es gibt ein äh systematischen Abgleich, der für alle gilt, die durch seine Passkontrolle gehen. Ähm,
Es war einmal, als wir biometrische Pässe bekommen haben, das Kernversprechen, dass es keine zentrale Biometriedatenbank geben würde,
Und es wurde jetzt immer versprochen, dass auch diese Daten nicht äh nichts gespeichert werden, sondern nur im Dokument wären.
Und das ist hier ein weiterer Schritt in die Richtung eben doch einer zentralen Datenbank von Biometriedaten von den erfassten Daten,
wenn du das gleich in den USA musst so die muss ja den Finger auf die auf den Scanner halten und so. Also es wird an den die Grenzkontrollen werden hier.
Ähm verstärkt und eine zentrale, ein zentraler Datenbankabgleich wird bei jedem stattfinden. Das hat.
Den CCC dazu animiert, mal wieder zu zeigen, wie man den äh wie man den Chip aus seinem Reisepass äh kaputt machen kann.
Das ist ja ein ähm RFID-Chip, also ein Chip, der Funken kann einerseits gleichzeitig aber keine eigene Spannungsversorgung hat. Ähm und diese Geräte funktionieren dadurch, dass quasi eine leichte Induktion.
Von dem Lesegerät stattfindet, die in dem Chip dann als Energiequelle dient, um den Chip dazu zu animieren, das zu tun, was er machen möchte, machen soll.
Funksturm.
Es ist wirklich, es ist richtiger Funkstrom, ja? Wie das Laden einer äh einer Zahnbürste oder einer Apple Watch oder so oder auch einiger Handys jetzt,
So ungefähr funktionieren diese Chips. So, wenn man aber jetzt auf der auf der richtigen Frequenz ähm einen etwas größeren Stromstoß rein geht, dann äh ist fließt eben auch ein relativ hoher Strom in diesem Chip.
Die ersten Versuche waren dann noch so mit, lege das mal in die Mikrowelle. Äh was dann dazu führte, dass es ein eben einen sehr großen äh also ein das,
Das gab dann einen Knall und das war dann auch sehr offensichtlich
Ähm weitere Experimente haben wir dann vorgenommen einfach mit der entsprechenden Größe Kondensator, dass du also ein Kondensator in um einen Puls zu geben, der dafür reicht, den Chip zu zerstören
Gleichzeitig ihn aber nicht direkt in Rauch und Flammen aufgehen zu lassen.
Und eher durch Zufall hatte Starbuck schon vor längerer Zeit entdeckt, dass äh wenn du so ein Induktionsherd hast,
Der der guckt ja quasi der setzt immer so jede Sekunde oder jede halbe Sekunde so ein Puls ab um zu erkennen ob er eine ob er am anderen Stelle ob am anderen ist,
ob dann eine Induktion stattfindet, ne? Also ob ob da ein induktives Gerät ist.
Und sonst hört der halt damit auf, ne? Also du hast, wenn du jetzt irgendwie den Herd anmachst, dann macht der also.
Und wenn du dann irgendwie mit der Pfanne dahin kommst und deren Ferienkern äh kriegt, wo er eine Induktionsstrom machen kann, dann dann geht diese gesamte Induktion an. Und dieser Puls,
ist glücklicherweise äh genau geeignet, um so einen Chit in so einem Reisepass und im, im neuen Epir so zu zerstören,
Ohne ohne dass da in Flammen aufgeht oder sonst was ist. Also offenbar genauso der Sweet Spot.
Womit du dein deinen AfID-Chip halt f.
Mehr als nur einem einzigen äh im.
Ja, ja, das äh äh das wurde.
Zur breiten Anwendung.
Das kam zur breiten Anwendung. Wir haben dann auch ein Video, äh wo das mit einem Reisepass gemacht wird und dann sieht man also, wird einmal vor den Lesern gehalten. Einmal einmal kurz an den Herd und dann wieder eine Leser. Also ihr müsst den nicht lange im Topf halten, ne, sondern keinen Topf
einmal so ein Puls und das Thema hat sich. Ähm.
Ist ja auch vor allem auch etwas, was einmal ganz normal wirklich passieren kann auch. Ja, also.
Da kann man nur vorwarnen, wie schnell das passiert. So, gleichzeitig ähm möchte ich aber an dieser Stelle dann auch so.
Gleich noch die EC-Karte dazu legen.
Muss ich überlegen, was man da nämlich, die EC-Karten haben aber andere Chips, das sollte bei denen nicht so schnell gehen, aber ich hoff.
Sicher? Was ist denn da anders.
Ach du meinst diese neuen ähm du meinst diese diese ach wie heißt was man jetzt in der Kreditkarte hat.
Die Kontaktlosen.
Äh das NFC? Ja, kann sein, also über passt auf, was er da drauf legt. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist ähm ich habe das nicht gemacht.
Und der Grund dafür ist, dass ich sehr, sehr häufig meinen Pass an der Kontrolle zeigen muss und
persönlich bei allem,
Bei allem Unwohlsein mit dieser Technologie mich ähm sehr über diese automatisierten Schengen, Schleusen in München und Frankfurt freue
wo ich mit dem modernen Reisepass sehr viel schneller durchkomme als Leute, die sich in die Schlange stellen müssen.
Das ist eine persönliche Abwägung, für die ich natürlich von vielen Leuten kritisiert werde, dass ich gefälligst meinen Pass kaputt machen soll. Ähm, die solltet ihr also auch haben, dass es unter Umständen also zu
jetzt zumindest diese Schnellverfahren, die auch in England zum Beispiel immer wieder bei der Einreise ganz angenehm sind, dass die dann eben für euch nicht mehr funktionieren und ihr unter Umständen in der längeren Schlange stehen müsst mit so einem Pass.
Muss man also abwägen.
Ähm das ist eben abzuwägen.
Man weiß es ja nicht. Es sei denn, es wird so endemisch.
Ja, die geht, das geht auch mal so kaputt, ne? Also es ist jetzt äh so also entscheidender Punkt ist, der Pass bleibt ein gültiges Ausweisdokument
Ja, ihr müsst jetzt nicht einen neuen Pass kaufen oder der ist jetzt auch nicht dann deswegen gefälscht oder oder sonst was, da kann euch keiner äh was ankreiden. Er hat ihm fehlt halt nur diese.
Aber was, was für Daten werden denn im Chip gespeichert, die sonst im nicht drin sind? Die biomet.
Biometrischen. Und das ist natürlich das Unschöne daran. Ähm du hast natürlich ohnehin der der Pass ist ja Maschinen lesbar.
Also ähm diese Schrift hat hier diese spezifische Schrift da drauf, die sich sehr einfach eignet und unten auf dem Pass steht quasi der Code, den du brauchst, um den Chip auszulesen.
Das war immer so ein ähm das war immer so die große Sorge, dass er dann irgendwie die Leute,
dem Vorübergehen erkennen und deine biometrischen Daten auslesen. Das geht nicht.
Das geht nur, wenn du vorher nochmal diesen Code.
Dafür brauchst du den Code, der da draufsteht. Deswegen legst du den Pass auch auf die ähm.
Also wenn du an so einer Schnellschleuse bist, hast du so ein Fenster, wo du den drauflegen musst mit dem eigentlichen Pasteil. Und dann wird der einmal, wird der quasi einmal erkannt, die Daten, die da draufstehen, die sind ja lesbar.
Man hat heute quasi den Private Key.
Und dann hat er das, hat er den Passcode, den er dem Chip geben muss, um zu sagen, okay, sag mal was auf Tet.
Ja und dann kriegt er halt diese diese Antworten und dann marschierst du weiter auf diese Gesichtserkennungskamera und dann bist du da durch.
Und sind außer der biometrischen Information noch andere Informationen da drauf.
Dass es leider drei Jahre her, dass ich das letzte Mal damit rumgespielt habe, deswegen kann ich dir nicht genau sagen, was da drauf steht.
Okay. Naja, müssen wir auch noch was fürs nächste Feedback haben, ne.
Da gibt's aber, das können wir. Ja, das können wir, könnt ihr mal zu Hause ausprobieren. Die Tools dafür gibt's irgendwie, da brauchst du eigentlich nur so ein ähm.
Ja, so eine ID Reader, Touchet-Tag oder irgendwas und die die Tools kann man sich im kann man sich runterladen. Da kann man übrigens auch ähm ganz schön diese NFC-Sachen auslesen. Macht auch.
Aber ich meine, ist ja ein bisschen absurd. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt an der Grenze stehe, so. Und jetzt habe ich Angst, dass die biometrischen Informationen, sprich mein Gesicht aus dem Pass ausgelesen werden. Ich stehe aber da an der Grenze und man muss einfach nur mal äh Kamera draufhalten.
Das Entscheidende ist, glaube ich, der der Datenabgleich, der stattfindet mit dieser zentralen Stelle.
Denn da werden ja diese Daten äh werden diese Daten abgeglichen und die Sorge, die sich hier eher, glaube ich, äh besteht, ist, dass es demnächst in eine äh eine zentrale Biometriedatenbank gibt.
Ja gut, aber wird's ja nicht ihr geben und äh die Frage ist, hilft der Chip an der Stelle äh oder verhindert der Chip New nicht nur, dass äh dass man überall noch Kameras noch dazu aufstellt, aber die gibt's dann wahrscheinlich eh wegen der Leute, die diesen Pass nie haben, ne?
Ich winke die ganze Zeit mit meinem Pferd.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht genau, was du mir damit sagen willst.
Abdruck.
Ach so. Äh ich dachte du wirst neun mal klug hier diesen Finger heben und sagen. Ja.
Nee, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Fingerabdruck. Auch drauf. Muss ja zwei Finger abgeben.
Na gut, aber auch den könnte man ja vor Ort neu.
Man kann alle, man kann Tim, man kann ganz viel vor Ort erfassen, ja, das stimmt. Äh machen auch die machen ja die USA hatte ich ja gerade erwähnt, aber das
scheidend ist, hast du eine äh hast du irgendwann eine Biometriedatenbank mit allen der allen mit automatisiert erfasst allen achtzig Millionen deutschen Bürgern beziehungsweise in dem Fall allen europäischen Bürgern. Und das ist hier
die Sorge, denn das Versprechen des Passgesetzes war
dass das nicht passiert und dass es nicht eine, dass es keine zentrale Speicherung der biometrischen Daten gibt. Und was hier gesehen wird, ist eine Entwicklung in diese Richtung.
Dann.
Ich habe das, glaube ich, also ne, das ist.
Ja, schön erklärt.
Dann haben wir noch eine kurze äh Bitte eines Hörers, der sagt, es äh gibt jetzt den Informatikbildungsplan in Baden-Württemberg,
in einer Anhörungsfassung für Klasse sieben und das sieht ungefähr so aus, dass man irgendwie das Pflichtfach für alle hat. Eine Stunde der in der Woche meist in geteilten Klassen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wonach die geteilt werden sollen. Anfangs nur im Gymnasium später
aber dann auch an anderen Schulen. So und jetzt gibt es den in der Klasse fünf gibt es dann äh einen Medienbildungskurs.
Ja sich erstmal nur mit Medien auseinandersetzen soll und ab ab Klasse acht bis zehn wird dann das
Prof Profilfach IMP. Informatik, Mathematik und Physik bei Herrn Doktor Axel Stoll äh Unterrichtet.
Und der wird, der wird gerade noch geschrieben.
Der wird vermutlich auch vor den Sommerferien öffentlich. Und unser Hörer wünscht sich dass man zu diesem Plan für Klasse sieben äh bis zum fünfzehnten siebten doch einfach mal Stellung nimmt und ähm die Pläne und die Rückmeldungsadresse gibt es unter,
HTP WWW Bildungspläne Minus PW Punkt DE.
Nein, die URL steht in den Shownots.
Entsprechende URL steht in den Showdowns, weil sie doch noch ein bisschen,
Länger ist, also wer sich da äh wer da mal drauf schauen und kommentieren möchte, ist herzlich dazu eingeladen, wenn ich dazu Gelegenheit finde, mache ich das vielleicht auch nochmal. Aber vor allem ist das ja vielleicht wichtig, dass es auch so.
Leute mit leer und Umgang mit Kindererfahrung machen.
Dann haben wir noch ein kleines Thema Übersprung gerade äh nämlich äh Vorratsseitenspeicherung. Ähm Nico Hertig äh der Rechtsanwalt Nico Hertig hatte auch nochmal versucht mit einem einen,
Eilantrag
in Kraft treten der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu unterbinden und den damit einher, der damit einhergehenden Verpflichtung für die Provider diese Infrastruktur zu errichten. Das war im Januar zweitausendsechzehn auch schon mal versucht worden, ist auch äh gescheitert in Karlsruhe. Ähm
im Juni dann wurden also diese Anträge abgelehnt,
einstweilige Verfügungen gegen diese Datenerhebungen wurden auch abgelehnt.
Und die Begründung mehr oder weniger dieses Bundesverfassungsgericht der Fahrt ist, die verfassungsrechtliche Bewertung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist nicht zur Klärung.
Allrechtschutzverfahren geeignet. Punkt. Ähm so war das.
Nicht so schnell, Mann.
Zum Allgemeinen, zur Allgemeinen stand die Bundestagsagentur hatte schon zweitausendsechzehn einen Anforderungskatalog für die Provider festgelegt
Ähm da bekommen also Investitionskosten für die Provider je nach Größe zwischen hunderttausend und fünfzehn Millionen Euro bei Rum. Diese sollen sich ohne Einbeziehung von Personalkosten auf insgesamt zweihundertsechzig Millionen Euro belaufen
Das hatten wir hier bei Lockwohnnetzwerk auch berichtet. Die IT-Wirtschaft ähm.
Hat er natürlich irgendwie eine andere Schätzung. Er wartet also unter Berücksichtigung von Personalkosten ungefähr sechshundert Millionen Euro kosten durch Umsetzung der Vorratsdatenspeicherungspläne. Also wir reden hier von einer nicht,
nicht unsignifikanten ähm äh,
Ausgabe, die auf unsere Wirtschaft zukommt. Der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Deutschen Bundestags hat ja im Oktober er hatte das hatte im Dezember zwanzigsechzehn auch schon Zweifel geäußert, dass dieses Gesetz
Die Vorgaben des EuGH erfüllen würde, also ein echt komischer,
Kahn, auf dem wir da gerade schippern. Aber die.
Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich da jetzt auf keine weiteren Eilverfahren eingelassen. Damit müssen die,
ähm Telekommunikationsanbieter ähm den Kram bis Ende Juni äh implementiert haben,
in der schönen, in der Pressemitteilung äh des äh
des Bundesverfassungsgericht findet sich der schöne Satz. Von einer weiteren Begründung wird nach Paragraph dreiundneunzig D Absatz eins Z drei, Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz abgesehen. Diese Entscheidung ist unanfechtbar, bitte gehen sie weiter,
Ähm das heißt, der schönste Fall, den man sich jetzt noch wünschen könnte, ist, dass die Provider dieses ganze Geld umsonst ausgeben müssen
Um diese Infrastruktur in Betrieb zu nehmen, damit sie dann erneut in anderthalb Jahren oder zwei oder wann auch immer, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich dann bequemt diesen nicht zum Eilverfahren geeigneten äh Fall zu behandeln.
Wieder ausschalten und was weiß ich. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht können wir das bis dahin nach Syrien oder Afghanistan oder oder in Audaudi Arabien verkaufen oder sowas.
Jetzt wäre noch der Mom.
Genau,
Ihr wisst es schon, hier geht's um Termine und äh die dürft ihr uns natürlich auch äh künftig äh schicken, denn wir haben eigentlich noch viel zu wenig davon. Es kommt immer mal wieder was und äh da wir jetzt so eine schöne, langes Musik
hier am Start haben, ist schon fast ein bisschen Verschwendung nur auf eine einzige Veranstaltung hinzuweisen, aber genau äh das macht hier Selinos.
Ja es gibt mal wieder die No Spike Konferenz, die ich glaube schon zum sechsten Mal stattfindet diesmal vom neunzehnten bis einundzwanzigsten Mai in Stuttgart. Themen sind Spionagen und Überwachung sowie der Schutz der Privatsphäre
Grundrechte, alle Infos gibt's auf HTTPS, äh Nosefighter
Unter anderem als Gäste vor Ort sind Peter Welchering, freier Journalist, der äh mir aber hauptsächlich vom Deutschlandfunk bekannt ist.
Ja, aber der sich halt schon seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten in diesem Gebiet äh super auskennt, selber auch sehr aktiv ist, äh,
nicht so direkt am Start hat hier Deutschlandfunk, äh, Computer und Kommunikation mit äh vielen anderen zusammen immer wieder an der Front.
Oder er spricht über digitales politisches Direktmarketing. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was das wird. Und ähm.
Äh ja und äh da sind wir doch schon wieder bei künstlicher Intelligenz, wa?
Und der der geschätzte äh Strafrechtler Rechtsanwalt Udo Vetter vom Lorblock sicherlich vielen bekannt. Äh sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, zwei Punkt null, aktuelle Strategien für den Umgang mit Polizei
und Staatsgewalt. Neunzehnter bis einundzwanzigster Mai
zweitausendsiebzehn sechste Note bei Konferenz im Literaturhaus Stuttgart.
Das könnte ja ein ein Leckerbissen werden, weil sie haben das Recht zu Schweigen. Eins Punkt null war ja ein, die da sagenumwobene Vortrag, den er mal auf dem äh siebenundzwanzig C drei, der auf dem Kongress gehalten hat,
der mit diesen unschlagbar großartigen Worten eingeleitet wurde, weil der ganze
Vortragsabwahr hat brechend voll und er meinte so, ja äh der Vortrag über Pornografie ist neben anderen Saal. Er würde sich ja sehr wundern, was hier los ist.
Aber er hat dann auch geliefert. Also den äh verlinken wir dann auch gleich nochmal hinterher. Wer dann Lust hat auf die zwei null, der muss nach Stuttgart. So,
Und damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal kurz der Hinweis ähm Termine machen wir glaube ich eigentlich nur auf Hinweis. Also wenn ihr na ich.
Ja, ja, wir kümmern uns jetzt nicht so groß, äh, es sei denn irgendwas zu irgendwas drängt sich auf, aber.
Ich hätte noch andere Veranstaltungen im in der in der Hand, aber manchmal habe ich dann auch so ein bisschen Sorge, dass die dann, wenn das kleine Veranstaltungen.
Gar nicht wollten, dass wir hier in unseren Mainstream-Pro.
Na ja, wenn also so bei kleineren Veranstaltungen kann das halt dann doch auch sein, dass du mit so einer Ankündigung halt mal.
Das alles irgendwie D-Dost.
Das den den Artikel, den den Kartenverkauf äh in Probleme fürs Fair. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie hier die, wie die,
die Rückmeldung so ist, aber vielleicht könnt ihr wenn ihr mal hier einen Termin angekündigt habt, uns ja auch sagen, ob das überhaupt was gebracht hat. Wir waren's ja jetzt äh eher als Service für unsere Hörner, irgendjemandem wird's bestimmt gefallen,
Bock drauf hat dahin zu gehen.
Genau, wir sitzen hier, essen, Schokokuchen und Dedos sind Kleinstveranstaltungen.
Nein. Didos ja nicht. Äh dafür machen wir das ja. Dafür hören die Leute die die ähm den Podcast ja zu viel zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten. Wahrscheinlich, wir würden das ja nicht wissen, wir würden's ja nicht.
Ihr sagt uns ja nix. Sagt doch mal was.
Also äh auch die Einladung hier in unserem ohnehin schon recht beliebten Kommentarspalte äh teilzuhaben, ist immer sehr äh nett und wenn ihr nichts zum Inhalt zu sagen habt, dann könnt ihr euch ja auch einfach an.
Anderen Dingen abarbeiten. Sommer.
Lob, Kritik, allgemeine Hinweise, alles gern gesehen.
Ja, es finde, es finden sich.
Wir haben Benutzerinteraktion.
Das hat der, hat der Google Marketing Mensch mir auch gesagt, das ist ganz wichtig.
Mit unser SEO-Potential.
Woch.
Somit wären wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt, die mal wieder länger geworden ist, da ist das vor, hatte und deswegen danke ich dafür, dem Steffen, dem Ahne, dem Thomas,
und einer unbekannten Person äh mal wieder die wie immer herzlich eingeladen ist, sich kurz bei mir zu melden. Sie sollte ja wissen, dass sie gemeint ist.
Und vielen anderen äh teilweise auch bekannten Personen für fortgesetzte Unterstützung. Das war's mit Lok Bundespolitik. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.